This episode of the podcast is brought
to you by blue apron.
Blue Apron is a really interesting new
podcast sponsor at that I really enjoy
because I like cooking,
but I've always been pretty cave man.
Like in my cooking.
I don't really use recipes.
I don't.
I don't buy cookbooks.
I mean I've read some recipes online for
certain things.
I got smoked ham before and things along
those lines.
It's kind of fun,
but I never really set out and cooked
meals.
I'm under very specific or rigid
instructions,
you know,
buying certain amount of recipe
ingredients and measuring it out and
I've never done that before.
Blue Apron and blue apron is a really
unique program where they send you the
food every week with detailed
photographic directions.
They send you the recipe.
It's really easy to follow and it's
delicious food.
It's like it's like eating out at an
interesting restaurant and you get to do
it yourself so you get this cool sense
of satisfaction after it's done.
Here's how it works.
For $9,
99 per meal.
They'll send you the right ingredients
in the exact right proportions with
simple recipe instructions right to your
door.
Meals are between 500 and 700 calories
per serving a,
although you really wouldn't guess it
because they're very delicious.
Uh,
you would think that you're cheating.
A blue apron includes step by step
directions.
Excuse me.
Blue Apron includes step by step
instructions with pictures.
So it's really idiot proof.
I've done it.
I've made quite a few things now and I
get new things that are delivered to me
every week.
New lists like this week,
they have also a vegetarian options as
well.
Um,
the vegetarian ones are like fresh
Gnocchi with A.
I don't even know.
How do you say this kind of mushrooms?
I'm a I,
t k e t a k e my talky talky mushrooms
Nokian my talky mushrooms and sweet corn
and brown butter time a pepper.
Our,
our repos,
a r e p Dot c dot.
It's all complicated.
Crafty food.
A chicken with candied pistachios and
snow.
Pea Radish Saute a Indian style salmon
with Tomato Chutney and cranberry bean
stew blts,
a Hayashi Chuko cold ramen.
Chicken breast with shrimp and Grits,
Mexican style beef,
stuffed red bell peppers.
Really yummy stuff.
Really interesting stuff too.
And it's fun to cook.
It's a,
it's like a little project I do.
It takes me about half an hour for each
meal and uh,
I enjoy it very much.
And if you're into something like that,
you should try it out.
Go to blue apron.com
forward slash rogen and you will get
your first two meals for free.
That's blue apron dot forward slash root
Rogan.
That's me,
Ron,
blue apron.com/Rogan.
You'll cook incredible meals and you,
you will really appreciate the quality
and the freshness of the food.
It's fast,
it's fresh and it's affordable.
That's blue apron.com.
Forward Slash rogen.
Uh,
we are also brought to you by stamps.com
stamps.com
is a,
another one of our longstanding podcast
sponsors that has been a.
I've heard nothing but positive
responses about it.
A lot of people use it.
Brian Red band uses it to send all of
his stuff from a desk squad dot TV.
A lot of our friends use stamps.com
because it's a really easy way to send
packages.
Going to the post office can be a
tremendous pain in the ass and with
stamps.com
you can avoid that and you can print
official us postage directly from your
computer,
either in your home or your office.
They provide you with a digital scale.
If you go to stamps.com
and click on the microphone in the upper
right hand corner and enter in the code
word j r e,
you will get a free digital scale and up
to $55 worth of free postage.
It's say $110 offer and when you get
that digital scale,
you simply way your packages print
official us postage with any normal
computer printer.
Slap that sucker right on the box and
boom,
hand it to the postman and you're done.
You don't have to deal with any of the
nonsense that comes with going to an
actual post office waiting in line.
Getting stuff measured out.
Stamps.com
is more powerful than a poet postage
meter and just a fraction of the cost of
it.
You will save up to 80 percent compared
to a postage meter.
I'll say that again because you're not
going to believe it.
You can save up to 80 percent compared
to a postage meter.
That's true and you avoid all the time
consuming trips to the post office.
We use stamps.com
and stamps.com
is an excellent choice.
If you have any sort of a home business
or an office where you send things out
of it's way easier than going to the
post office.
Now when you go to stamps.com,
before you do anything,
click on the microphone and the top of
the homepage and type in j r e that
stamps.com
and enter the code word j r e for your
$110 bonus offer,
which again includes up to $55 in free
postage and a digital scale that you're
not supposed to use for mushrooms are.
We don't use them.
And last but not least,
we are brought to you by [inaudible] dot
com.
That is o n n I t,
if you have not heard on it,
has the latest and greatest in our
kettlebell series.
This,
uh,
the new ones are called the legend
kettle bells.
Um,
we're,
we're at a Zombie kettlebells for now,
getting them in,
but we now have the Werewolf and the
Werewolf is a pretty dope delicious.
And uh,
it is 62 pounds.
All of the kettlebells that we have,
the artistic kettlebells,
they are all three d balanced.
And what that means by 3d balances,
they look cool,
but they're also balanced correctly.
Uh,
you don't want anything to be weighted
too heavily on one side.
And that way it sort of defeats the
whole purpose of making a Kettlebell.
They also have extra large handles for
enhanced grip strength.
I can't say it enough.
I am a huge fan of working out with
kettlebells is the main method that I
use for strength and conditioning
training.
And,
uh,
it's benefited true me tremendously.
Uh,
what they are is they're essentially
these giant balls of iron with these
huge metal handles,
these iron handles,
and you swing them around and uh,
in doing so,
it promotes what they call functional
strength.
We have several workout dvds that are
also for sale at [inaudible] dot com and
not just a dvds for kettlebells,
but also dvds for sandbag workouts,
a dvds for steel mace workouts,
dvds,
uh,
for,
um,
just all sorts of different body weight
training exercises as well.
We have a huge selection now and
including my favorite,
which is the extreme kettlebell cardio
workout DVD,
the extreme kettle bell cardio too
extreme to Kettlebell cardio workout
DVD,
which is the latest and greatest by
Keith Weber who will be on the show next
month.
We also have a wide variety of
supplements and foods,
foods including hemp force protein,
a earth grown nutrients,
which is an excellent supplement to add
to your morning shake to ensure you're
getting your daily amount of Greens.
Really a super healthy stuff with
antioxidants,
a powerful Greens from both land and the
sea,
wheat grass,
barley grass,
oat grass,
Kale,
kelp,
all sorts of different stuff.
Spirulina,
Alfalfa,
um,
just the idea behind it.
Just getting as many nutrients into your
body as you can,
especially earth grown nutrients.
Really healthy,
natural,
easy for your body to digest.
I'm with five major components.
All have it listed at [inaudible] dot
com.
And the other things long.
The food lines are the warrior bar,
which is another big favorite of mine,
which is natural organic buffalo meat.
No antibiotics,
no added hormones.
It's Buffalo Meat Preston,
an ancient lakota recipe,
um,
with,
uh,
no,
no added preservatives.
The way,
the way it's done as the same way they
used to do it probably more than a
thousand years ago.
It has only 140 calories,
but with 14 grams of protein and four
grams of fat for every two ounce serving
very healthy and it doesn't feel,
you know,
you can satisfy your cravings and your
hunger and you don't feel like a dummy
for doing so.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n it,
and use the Codeword Rogan and you will
save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
We are a human optimization website and,
uh,
even if you don't go to on it and
purchase things,
there's just a huge source of
interesting stuff at the onnit academy.
I'm lots of fantastic workouts that you
can check out and a lot of inspirational
stuff.
Great articles.
The onnit academy is one of the,
uh,
the newest and expanding forms,
a add on it,
not expanding forums,
but forums at onnit pages at onnit.
Lots of really cool stuff there,
um,
that you have that you could go there
and just get it for free,
but if you want to buy anything used the
cohort Rogan and you'll save 10 percent
off any and all supplements.
All right.
Rupert sheldrake is here.
Cue The music.
Young James.
Yeah,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Thank you very patients.
Rupert,
Rupert Sheldrake,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Uh,
I've,
uh,
I,
I came to know of you through the trial
logs that you did with Terence Mckenna,
who I'm a huge fan of.
And Ralph Abraham,
and I thought they were some really
fascinating conversations and you know,
all terrence's mp3s are very,
very thought inspiring and made you
really like look at things from a very
different in peculiar angle that he had
a,
he had a very unique way of looking at
the world.
But I came to know of you from that and
I came to know of your ideas of morphic
resonance,
which I found to be really fascinating.
And if you don't mind just explain to
folks at home listening what the concept
of morphic resonance is.
It's the idea of memory in nature.
The idea that the whole universe has a
kind of memory to so called laws of
nature are more like habits.
Each individual in this species draws on
a collective memory and contributes to
it.
It works on the base of similarity.
Any pattern of activity similar to a
later pattern of activity in a self
organizing system influences it across
space and time.
So what it means in effect is that if
you train rats to learn a new trick in
Los Angeles and rats in New York and
Sydney and London will learn the same
thing quicker,
straight away at the sanctuary evidence
that this surprising effect happens if
you crystallize a new chemical that's
never existed before,
and then after you've made him one
place,
it should get easier to Christianize or
all over the world.
So it's really a theory of habit and
memory and um,
it enables new patterns of learning to
spread quicker than they might otherwise
do.
And it means that it should get easier
to learn things that other people have
already learned.
So this has been proven,
this,
this concept of rats being able to learn
one thing in New York a quicker because
they learned it already in San
Francisco.
Yes.
I mean it wasn't done to test morphic
resonance,
which is still very controversial.
It was done to test something else.
It was done in,
in years ago before the Second World
War.
A professor at Harvard called William
McDougall wanted to find out if rats
could learn quicker what their parents
had learned.
So he trained these rats to escape from
the water maze.
They had to swim.
If they went out the wrong exit,
they got an electric shock and if they
weren't at the right exit,
which was the wrong one,
was lit up with a light.
The other one was dim.
If they went out the right exit,
they just escaped from the maze and he
tested them to see how many trials
they've made before they learned,
always go out of the DMX.
It.
And the first generation took about 250
trials before they cottoned onto what
was happening.
The next generation,
it was about 180 trials.
about 150,
they got better and better.
And,
and he thought at first this was because
there was something being passed on to
the children may be through modifying
the jeans or something like that,
an inheritance for client characters.
That was a kind of taboo in 20th century
science.
Um,
and so people questioned his work,
but because he was at Harvard and
because he was a famous professor,
um,
they couldn't just dismiss it,
he showed a huge effect.
Um,
so people tried repeating his work in
the University of Edinburgh,
Scotland and Melbourne,
Australia,
and they found that there at started
more or less where the Harvard rats had
left off and in Melbourne they did an
experiment that was particularly
interesting.
They went on getting better,
the ones that were descended from the
train parents in each generation,
but they found that all rats of that
breed,
even if their parents had never been
trained,
we're getting better too.
So whatever it was,
it wasn't something to do with modifying
the genes or what people would now call
epigenetics.
There was something else,
much more mysterious going on and since
no one knew what it was,
uh,
it was just ignored and forgotten.
That is really fascinating.
So that would kind of make sense that
if,
if somehow or another the jeans or
whatever that is in the rat is able to
communicate with other of the same
species over the,
have a similar genetics of whatever it
is that they're doing,
whatever undefined thing that they're
doing,
connecting with them even across
continents,
across the other side of the planet.
Yes.
Wow.
That's right.
And so the same mood.
I think the same happens in evolution
naturally in nature.
There was a famous case with um,
birds called blue tits and England and
America,
you call them chickadees,
put that in the 19 twenties,
started rating milk bottles in Britain
we had then.
And we still have a system where you get
fresh milk delivered to your doorstep
everyday in a bottle and then they wash
the bottles and use them as a great
system.
We have right now in London.
Um,
so in the 19,
20 years they had caught,
bought tops on these bottles and someone
gnosis in Southampton,
the cream at the top of their bottle had
disappeared.
The top had been tornado and the cream
of disappeared.
And when they watched,
they sold that every morning these
pollutants in Southampton had figured
out they could tear off this cardboard
strip and get free cream every morning.
And then everyone sort of interested in
this.
Then it turned up many,
many miles away in another part of
Britain and it turned up somewhere else.
Bluetooth's don't fly very far.
Their home loving birds and they don't
migrate.
So,
um,
scientists got interested and they set
up a network all over Britain of people
to observe this habit.
And they got reports.
It was coordinated from Cambridge
University and they mapped the spread of
the habit and it became clear that it
was spreading faster and faster and it
was being independently invest in,
invented in other parts of Britain.
So much so that the professor of biology
at Oxford surrenders to hardy,
suggested it must be happening by
telepathy and that it was spreading too
quickly.
And the most interesting records from
Holland because this started happening
in Holland as well.
And during the war,
Holland was occupied by the Germans and
milk deliveries stopped.
They didn't start again until about
1948,
but seven or eight years after they
stopped Bluetooth's only live three or
four years.
So there would've been no bluetooth's
after the war that remembered the golden
age of free cream.
Um,
so,
um,
when they milk deliveries began again in
Holland,
they started drinking the cream almost
straightaway,
all over Holland.
So I would say this is a kind of
collective memory that spread by morphic
resonance and was remembered by morphic
resonance.
Um,
and that's another example of this going
on in the real world.
Incidentally,
I'm,
they've now stopped doing it.
They used to steal our cream in London
until about 10 years ago when we
switched to semi skimmed milk.
There isn't any cream on bottles of semi
skimmed milk and Bluetooth's have more
or less given up in Britain because 70
people have switched to semi skimmed
milk.
They don't get any cream.
It's not worth the effort.
So I'm at the habits died out.
That's pretty fascinating.
The idea that human beings start off as
a blank slate has really been questioned
quite a bit over the last generation and
a genetics in particular.
They're starting to understand that
there's certain particular traits and
memories that you can actually learn
from your parents.
Like there was one study they did with
mice where they had taken mice and they
had given them an electric shock and
coincided that electric shock with the
smell of citrus hill.
There was electric shock and their feet.
Are you aware of this test?
Yes,
I am.
It was published in nature with a
provocative title,
inheriting the fears of fathers.
It's a very,
very fascinating study.
Amazing staff.
I mean that I think could be partly due
to morphic resonance,
so have you explained it to people
before?
I might have,
but please do.
Well,
what they did was they used a chemical
synthetic chemical called acetone for
known that smells sort of vaguely
fruity,
but it's something that mice would never
have encountered in nature because it's
a synthetic chemical and they took male
mice and expose them to smell of acetone
who known and they gave them a mild
electric shock on their poor when they
smelled this stuff.
Um,
and the result is classical Pavlovian
conditioning,
you know,
a few times of that happening as soon as
they smelled acetone now.
And they were terrified.
I'm perfectly standard stuff in science.
What wasn't standard was the then bread
from these mice and they did some of the
experiments using artificial
insemination so that the mothers never
even met the fathers of the next
generation.
And then they tested their children and
their grandchildren and whenever they
smelt acetone for known,
they were just paralyzed with fear.
So the inherited the fear of this
chemical in a single generation,
um,
in a way that regular science simply
can't explain.
Um,
and this went far beyond anything anyone
would have expected.
There's evidence from the details of the
experiments that involved some changes
in the sperm,
some change in the genes or the
epigenetics,
which is the packaging if the genes,
but no one can conceive how a mouse
learning to avoid this smell and being
frightened by it all that they were,
knows how all that information could be
transferred into genes and the sperm.
So I think at least part of the
explanation of this is morphic resonance
that if you make some animals adverse to
something,
then they're deciding,
well,
other animals have the same kind will be
frightened of it.
I did a very similar experiments
actually years ago with a skeptical
scientist in Britain called Steven rose.
Um,
we had a controversy in the Guardian
newspaper.
I wrote her.
I used to write a column in the Guardian
and I wrote a thing about the nature of
memory and how morphic resonance helps
to explain it.
We can discuss that later if you'd like,
but that rose was outraged by this.
He'd spent his whole career working on
memory saying must be inside the brain.
And he worked with day old chicks and in
the Guardian he wrote a response to my
article and challenged me to do an
experiment in his laboratory under his
supervision to test what he called this
seemingly absurd hypothesis.
Um,
well,
uh,
what the,
the experiment we did,
we had dale chicks and Dale chicks peck
at anything bright.
So we had them packet silvery bead work.
And after the silverbeet they're
injected with saline solution is just a
control.
They,
they didn't feel early.
Everything was fine.
We also had them pack at a yellow light
emitting diode and after they'd packed
at that,
the checks that had packed at the yellow
light emitting diode were injected with
something that made them feel sick.
Lithium chloride,
I think it was,
it made them feel sick.
It didn't kill me,
it just made them feel ill.
And you know,
if you ever eat anything and you feel
sick after it,
you,
you never want to eat that thing again.
It's,
it's a,
it's called conditioned to Vashon.
And so these checks,
when you tested them a day or two later,
they would avoid yellow lights,
but they'd pack at the chrome bead,
the silverbeet,
which hadn't made them sick and that's
straightforward.
They learned to avoid it.
But what I predicted was that in,
so we,
if we did the experiment over and over
again,
every day we get a new batch of fresh
chicks and test them with the yellow,
a light emitting diode and the chrome
bead.
Um,
I predicted that they'd start avoiding
the yellow light emitting diode.
Um,
but not the chrome bead,
because of the influence by morphic
resonance from previous checks.
They'd start avoiding it even before
they'd been made of us to it for the
first time they were exposed to it.
They,
they wouldn't go for it,
they'd,
they'd be more wary of it.
And that's exactly what happened in this
experiment.
Um,
so this is actually something that's
well known in the rat poison industry.
I mean,
most people haven't spent much time
looking into the rat poison industry and
how it works.
But one thing that happens to people who
try to poison rats for a living is that
if you try some new kind of bait with a
particular flavor,
I'm rats eat it and they get sick and
they die.
Um,
but it works for awhile.
But after awhile,
rat start avoiding it.
They become what's called in the trade
bait shy,
um,
and not just in one place,
but the bait stops working,
you know,
miles and miles away.
So you have to keep inventing new bates.
That's why most rat poison,
no is based on warfare in which causes
bleeding,
um,
thins the blood and causes bleeding.
And it doesn't usually affect the rats
for days after they've eaten it.
They don't associate it with any
particular flavor because it's slow,
slow acting.
That's why people have had to switch to
Warfarin as the main rat poison because
this aversion to things that poison
became so strong and to something that
actually some people who are listening
to us might know about,
which I heard from a guy in America who
fishes for Bass and he was telling me
there's a constant development of new
lawyers for bass fishing.
I do do,
do,
do fish quite a bit.
Yes.
Well apparently people are always
inventing new lawyers that worked very
well for awhile and apparently then they
stopped working and not just in one
place but elsewhere.
So it was a constant development of new
lawyers.
Now,
if that could be documented,
um,
that might be another very interesting
case of morphic resonance.
If Bass keep getting caught and they're
in pain when they're caught by being
finished with a particular kind of Leer,
then other bass later evening,
different rivers or lakes,
um,
uh,
when they see that,
you know,
it would be more averse to biting it.
So it stops working.
So I think there could be many examples
of this.
I'm out there in the real world.
When did you come up with this concept?
Is this your concept,
the concept of morphic resonance?
Resonance?
Yes.
I,
I came up with this in 1973,
long time ago.
I was doing research at Cambridge
University on plant development,
how plants grow and I became convinced
for a variety of reasons that,
um,
the attempt to explain the whole thing
just in terms of genes and molecules and
proteins wouldn't work.
Um,
I was at the very leading edge of this.
I mean the main plant hormone is called
Oxen Aux Ian and I figured out how it's
made and then I figured out how it's
transplanted,
transported around the plant and this
was a massive advance and this is kind
of textbook stuff now in,
in,
in school,
in University of textbooks,
the mechanism of polar oxygen transport.
So having figured all that out,
I then realized this wasn't enough to
explain plants because all plants have
the same hormone and it's moved in the
same way in every plant and it's moved
to the same way and petals and leaves
and stems and roots.
And it's moved to the same way in palms
and cabbages and roses,
and yet they're all different.
So I got interested in something in
biology called morphogenetic fields,
the idea of invisible fields,
the shape living organisms.
So there's like an invisible mold as a
flower grows,
it's kind of invisible mold that shapes
the way the petals develop and the
flower develops or as a leaf grows,
that's kind of invisible mold for that
leaf called the morphogenetic field,
like a kind of an invisible plan.
This idea was not invented by me,
it had been around in biology since the
19 years,
but the key thing was to understand how
these fields could be inherited.
And I was sure it wouldn't go through
the jeans,
just code for proteins.
So they had to be some other kind of
inheritance.
How could it work?
And I was wrestling with this idea in
Cambridge and then the idea of morphic
resonance came to me.
If you have a resonance across time
between similar things,
you could explain this inheritance of
form and have instincts in animals in a
non-genetic way,
which would give a completely new way of
understanding biology and inheritance.
I then realized that this would apply to
learning and memory and many aspects of
human behavior.
So I wrote this up in a book called a
new science of life,
which was published in 1981.
It took me years to think this through.
I realized that it would be
controversial.
Um,
so I had to be very sure of myself
before I could write about it.
Then I wrote another book called the
presence of the past which puts the
theory forward in its fullest form.
And that's my main theoretical book and
since then I've really been trying to
develop these ideas,
test them,
do experiments and so on.
Anyway,
it was my idea in the first place and
since then it's become widely discussed
in many areas.
And when you say that you,
um,
had to be sure of it,
what did you do that made you sure of
it?
I mean,
what is a,
what,
what kind of testing have you done to
sort of hammer out this concept of
morphic residence?
Well,
there were two aspects to being sure
about it.
The,
the main objection that I got from my
colleagues and in the scientific world,
especially in biology,
um,
was not that they not.
What's the evidence?
They didn't say,
what's the evidence they just said this
idea is unnecessary because we're going
to figure everything out in terms of
genes and molecular biology.
Um,
so one line of research I had to do was
to see whether the conventional approach
in biology was likely to work or not.
Um,
and so I had to think really deep about
standard science.
Um,
is this going to work it,
they just said,
give us time.
We'll figure it all that we don't need
new ideas.
We basically,
everything's fine the way it is.
And that's what led in the 19 eighties
to people formulating the human genome
project and um,
which culminated in the year 2000 with
the publication of the human genome.
So they thought that that was adequate
to explain.
Once they got into the human genome,
once they mapped it out,
that was going to,
they're going to be able explain pretty
much everything about human being.
That's right.
They actually thought that.
And that's why there was a huge
investment.
Hundreds of billions of dollars were
invested in genomics and biotechnology
on the grounds that gene's explain
everything.
One Gene,
one characteristic does a gene for
everything.
If you can figure out the genes and
manipulate the genes,
basically you can control life.
And if you can own the genes or own
patients on the jeans,
you can make billions of dollars.
That was the thinking and that was
almost everybody was into that.
But I was convinced that genes were
grossly overrated,
that they couldn't do most of these
things that people thought they could.
Um,
because what genes do is code for the
sequence of amino acids in proteins,
protein molecules which make up our
muscles and you know,
the blood cells and they're the enzymes.
And so on,
a major part of life.
Um,
I'm a coded for by genes,
but there's a huge difference between
making the right proteins and the shape
of your nose,
for example,
or the instincts of a spider to spin a
web.
I mean,
it's,
it's like saying you could explain the
structure of the building by knowing the
chemistry of the bricks.
I mean you have to have breaks and you
have to have cement and timber and stuff
to make a building.
Um,
and if you have defective bricks,
you get a defective building,
but it doesn't explain the plan of the
building,
the shape of the building.
So I was convinced that these things
would never be explained by genes that
we needed something like morphogenetic
fields and morphic resonance to explain
them.
So part of thinking about this was
thinking hard about what regular science
coach and could not achieve.
And incidentally,
I'll come to the evidence in a minute,
but the,
um,
one of my predictions that there's
biotechnology thing would be a disaster.
It would mean people lose huge amounts
of money.
I advised my friends if they are
investors,
just don't bother,
you know,
the only way you make money in this is
by getting in on the bubble and selling
art in time because it's not really
going to lead to that many useful
product.
Why are you so convinced?
Because I thought that the role of genes
was totally overrated and um,
this is in fact what's happened.
Were you alone in this or were there
some,
a few people.
There are a few people,
but most people went along with this,
you know,
it's interesting.
You see that the human genome project,
they expected they'd have about 100,000
genes that turned out when they finally
announced that there were only about
20,000
genes,
we have less genes in the Seattle region
and about half as many as a rice plant.
That was a huge surprise to people and
it soon became clear that it wasn't
going to deliver on most of these
promises.
Craig venter,
who had the private genome project,
which was a rival of the publicly funded
one.
He's in a very,
very competitive guy.
Got He got there first.
You know,
he saw it as a race and he was going to
win and he did.
Um,
and uh,
even though he was technically very
successful and the publicly funded
genome project was technically
successful,
once they'd done it,
it became immediately apparent this
information was almost useless.
And Craig venter's,
his company is Celera genomics.
The shares collapsed in a few days from
about $60 a share to about twelve cents
a share.
And when he was interviewed after that,
he said he's got a great sense of humor.
He said,
he said,
I'm a guy who's made a million the hard
way by working my way down from a
billion.
The thing is,
it didn't work.
And yeah,
in around four or five years ago,
um,
there was a development in science that
most people haven't heard of yet outside
science,
but it's really big within the
scientific journals called the missing
heritability problem at.
What they did is they took the genomes
of 30,000
different people because it's quite
cheap now to sequence genomes sequenced
about 30,000
genomes.
And to figure out what genes do what you
know,
they looked at the people,
30,000
people that they knew everything about
their height,
their diseases history and so forth.
They started with height [inaudible]
heights,
easy to measure.
You just need a tape measure and it's
already known that tall parents tend to
have taught children in short,
parents tend to have short children.
You can predict the height of children
when they're grown on the basis of the
parent's height with an accuracy of
about 80 percent.
And in the technical language,
they say height is 80 percent heritable.
Well,
they'd figured out that the genes
complete genome of 30,000
different people.
They knew their height,
so they then ran all these correlations
and statistics to figure out which genes
are involved in height.
And they found about 50 genes are
involved in controlling height.
Then they say they found some are more
important than others.
So they made their best models waiting
some more than others and coming out
with predictions and then they picked
some people at random.
The genomes,
they'd did all their sums.
They'd identified the genes,
they ran the computer simulations,
and they predicted these people's
heights on the base of their genome,
and then they looked up the height to
see how good this method was.
It turned out they could predict,
hiked with an accuracy of five percent.
Now you can do it with an actress of 80
percent just by using tape measures in a
way that it's billions of dollars
cheaper.
Um,
so,
um,
they,
uh,
the,
the gap between the five percent and the
80 percent,
the 75 percent is not explained by the
genes,
is called the missing heritability
problem.
And it turned out that the same was true
of most diseases for it.
There's a few diseases where a defective
gene gives a defective protein and you
get a clear predictive values.
Cystic fibrosis is one of them.
Sickle cell anemia is another.
So there's a few rare genetic diseases
where this method works very well,
but for most diseases,
breast,
cardiac problems,
the predictive value of the GE name
turned out to be only five to 10
percent.
And all these companies sprang up that
would offer to sequence people's
genomes.
And predict their diseases and the last
one,
23 and me,
it was put out of business by the FDA,
uh,
just a few months ago because they're
advertising was misleading.
They,
they cannot predict with more than about
10 percent accuracy the likelihood that
you'll get a particular gi disease on
the base of the genome,
except for these rare genetic disorders.
So this company,
their entire business model was
predicting people's vulnerability to
certain diseases.
I think that was their main business
model.
I mean there are certain things where
genome sequencing is still valuable and
used,
you know,
if you want,
find out what your racial background is,
you know,
where did your ancestors come from?
It's really good for that.
And it has very useful information.
I'm not saying this is useless,
I'm saying it's,
it has limited uses,
but nothing like the bonanza of profits
that people were expecting.
There was a report by the Harvard
Business School on this a few years ago
on the biotech business and they said no
one had ever invented such a massive
money losing scheme in the history of
humanity.
So I think that's because it was based
on a false assumption of what genes do
is.
That's fascinating.
What is the,
when when people hear about the
experiment with the,
uh,
the mice and the smell,
what's the smell?
Call again?
The acetone,
acetone.
What's the conventional explanation for
this?
Uh,
this memory being passed down into these
animals that have never experienced that
before,
through,
through breeding.
Well,
there isn't really one you see because
the,
it's something that Peter has rightly
surprised about because the idea that
you could actually do that,
you could give off the brain or of the
nose or could actually give off
influences that travel through the blood
and selectively modify sperm changing
genes or the packaging of jeans.
Nothing like that had been contemplated
before.
And this suggests something going is
going on that regular science doesn't
know about.
And that's fine from the point of view
of science.
I mean if you discover something new,
then you have to try and figure out how
it works,
but no one really knows.
And this sort of pushes molecular
biology beyond its limits really.
And people are working on this now and
trying to figure out how it could
happen.
What are the conventional theories is,
are there any.
Well,
there aren't really,
I mean no one knows how I'm smelling
something could affect genes or the
packaging of jeans.
Um,
and even if they could even,
if you could say there'd be a
modification of the sperm to make
people.
Most of the offspring,
the mice that descend from those sperm
more sensitive to Acetate for noon.
That doesn't necessarily explain why
they'd be afraid of it.
I mean it,
if they trained me in a different way,
acetone for known could have.
They could lick their lips and thought,
oh,
this means food.
So you've got quite a lot of explaining
to do and how these genes or the
packaging of them could influence the
brain is way beyond anything we can
understand at present.
So I think most people would say we just
don't,
haven't figured it out yet.
And this is a fairly recent experiment.
Two months ago,
a few months ago,
realized it was published a few months
ago.
How long did they work on this for
though?
Well,
I suppose they must have been working on
it for several years before they
published it,
but I mean,
what's exciting in biology at the moment
is that the standard off the shelf
explanations that people used to have.
It's all genetically programmed and that
kind of thing.
This is falling apart until the year
2000.
There was a huge taboo in biology
against the inheritance of acquired
characteristics,
which means say a father builds up his
muscles and become stronger and our
learns particular skills.
The idea that the children could inherit
that was considered impossible.
It they said no,
it's all inheritances.
Just genetic.
Of course you get environmental
influences.
If,
if a dad takes his boys to weight
lifting classes and stuff,
then obviously they'll become more
muscular.
Um,
but the idea that it could be anything
could be passed through the genes that
had been learned or acquired was
absolutely to Bu.
It was a heresy in 20th century biology
in the West.
Interestingly,
in the Soviet Union,
they went the other way,
started in like the idea that if people
got better at things that our kids would
be better at them,
automatically they'd inherited and
geneticists in the Soviet Union were
persecuted and people who did research
on the inheritance of acquired
characteristics.
We're well funded and prestigious and
this polarized things even more.
There was a kind of cold war in biology
as well as in everything else.
But around the year 2000,
it became clear that the really is an
inheritance of acquired characteristics
and it's been rebranded epigenetic
inheritance.
Um,
and it's now a really hot topic in
biology.
And these mice inheriting the fear of
their fathers experiments,
a part of this new wave of research on
epigenetics.
And it turns out that a lot of things
the Soviet biologists were claiming are
actually true.
I'm.
One of the things I think ought to
happen is that somebody who knows
Russian,
preferably someone who's in Russia goes
back through these archives of Soviet
biology from the 19 twenties,
thirties,
forties,
and fifties when tens of thousands of
biologists and the Soviet Union were
working on what we now call epigenetic
inheritance and,
um,
it's a mine of information that could be
dusted off and could be really helpful
to science,
but nobody's done that yet because it's
usually assumed the whole of that's been
discredited.
And,
and even Russians don't want to talk
about it.
That's so fascinating.
It's so fascinating that,
that scientists are just now piecing
together this new information.
Just start putting it together and pure.
It's purely anecdotal evidence.
I have young daughters and they wrestle
around together and you know,
they play in the bed and laugh and joke
and I've been doing Jujitsu since the 19
nineties and my daughter's assumed
Jujitsu positions.
I see them do it before.
I've taught them now,
but when they were little,
like three and four years old,
my,
my youngest would do what's called an
over under control.
She would grab her back and grip like a
certain way that you teach people to do
and then she would throw her legs over.
It's called taking the back.
It's a.
it's a position,
a standard position in Jujitsu,
but it's not a normal position for
people,
but she would automatically go to it,
pull my older daughter on top of her and
take her back and it was the craziest
thing to watch as a martial arts
commentator,
someone who understands,
you know the correct way to do
positions.
I would watch her do it.
I was like,
she knows what she's doing.
I don't think she knows why she knows
what she's doing,
but she assumed a position that I've
done countless times,
thousands of times in my life.
It automatically came to her and I'm
like,
that has to be somehow or another in her
code.
Somehow or another,
it's gone from my body.
Exactly.
Whether it's a really,
really interesting case and you see,
I would call that morphic resonance that
she's resonating with us.
She's got your jeans,
he's caught your proteins and those of
her mother as well,
of course.
Um,
but this similarity to you means she'd
be in a particular strong resonance with
you and would pick up things that you've
acquired.
And I think it's interesting you see in
many traditional societies,
children would follow in the footsteps
of their parents,
you know,
blacksmiths,
sons had become blacksmiths.
And in India,
the caste system,
you know,
if someone's a potter,
they're kids that become potters and if
they're a weaver,
they're kids that become weavers.
And um,
I think this is partly because people
would have a special aptitude for doing
things their parents had done for skills
their parents had acquired,
not through the genes but by a kind of
resonance obviously training and growing
up in a household where people know
these things plays an important part.
But even before the regular training
begins,
you'd expect them to show these
tendencies.
And so that's a particularly interesting
example because you're able to observe
these positions most people wouldn't
notice.
But,
um,
that's the kind of thing that I think is
likely to be going on all the time.
Yeah,
there's been several of those positions
there.
I mean,
sometimes it's just play.
And I see them just rolling around,
but then there's these clear patterns,
like one of them is a knee to belly to
the mount.
There's this position that you do when
you're in what's called side control.
You put your knee on someone's stomach,
you slide it across,
and you get on top of the mounting them
with your hips above their hips and she
does it.
It instinctively.
And it's not an instinctive move for
most kids.
And I try to,
I try to be objective when I watch it.
Like how much of this is just natural
human movement and how much of this is
like her actually having some
information and there's clear blips
where I go look at that data that is
normal like in Jujitsu class,
but it's not normal for kids.
Like there's,
there are things that they've learned.
And then there's also like when I've
taught them stuff,
they pick things up.
Like they already knew it.
It's like I used to teach martial arts.
So I've taught quite a few people and I
know children are a little easier to
teach than than other folks,
but there's children of people who are
martial artists and then there's
children of people who have never
studied martial arts and the children of
people who are martial artists were
almost universally easier to teach.
And it sort of backs up that idea.
Yes.
I mean,
one could even do experiments on this,
actually quantify it.
I'm my own approach to science is that
you have to start from what people have
noticed,
like your observations with kids of
martial arts people including your own.
And then if you want to take it further,
you could do more rigorous observations
and just standard explanation.
People say,
Oh,
well they've seen their parents do to
alucien videos or pictures of it around
the house and that sort of thing.
That might play some part in it.
But,
um,
I think there's likely to be much more
than that to this and when we'd
obviously have to do special experiments
too chunky out.
Um,
I mentioned,
I think in many areas,
um,
it should be easier to teach kids whose
parents have done something like my own
kids.
My two sons are extremely musical,
brilliant,
new musical ones,
a professional musician.
Um,
well I play the piano.
My grandfather was a church organist.
My uncle was a church organist.
My father was very musical.
My mother was,
played the piano and was very musical.
My wife's family were musical.
Her mother was a concert pianist who
found it was a pianist and a singer,
and right from the age of four,
they wanted to play the piano.
They wanted to learn music and they
shared a tremendous amount of ability to
assimilate it.
There are sometimes people who are very
musical who come from non musical
families,
but some of the greatest musical
geniuses come out of musical dentist is
like buck.
I mean,
he came from a dentistry of musicians.
And so I think that these,
uh,
these things are probably easier to
learn if parents have learned them.
It's so fascinating.
Just the,
the concept of learning things and
learning things from some really an
known source.
One of the things that you brought up in
the trial logs
I thought was particularly interesting
and really resonated with me was you
were talking about how children in New
York City are afraid of monsters,
that it's a natural inclination for
children to be afraid of things in the
dark with large teeth that are going to
eat you.
And that this goes back to the time
where we were regularly.
Predators took babies.
They like big cats are monsters as it
were in the night,
would steal people,
would eat.
People prayed,
preyed on human beings.
That it makes sense that these children
have this intuitive instinct built into
their genetics or whatever it is.
Well,
exactly.
I mean,
the,
the standard.
So to true,
the human prehistoric past his man,
the hunter,
striding out onto the savannas of Africa
and stuff.
But,
um,
it was much more,
I think the case man,
the hunted.
I mean,
humans are particularly defenseless
against big predators and until recent
times were very vulnerable to them.
Like Tigers in India,
during the,
under the British rule,
even as late as 19 forties,
um,
there were thousands of people a year
killed by managing tigers and they
usually go for the most vulnerable.
I mean,
when predators are working in Africa,
when lions are attacking herds of
antelope or something,
they go for the old and the sick or they
go for the young because they are the
ones that are the most vulnerable.
So probably over huge amounts of human
history,
young children had indeed been eaten by
predators and um,
and still wear.
And,
and probably today in some parts were
maybe still are.
These were the most realistic fears for
huge periods of human history.
And so I think it's fascinating that I'm
young children have these nightmares.
The study in New York looked at the
nightmares of young children.
Nearly all of them were about being
chased by monsters or scary animals.
Um,
and of course we feed this imagination
in children's through fairytales.
Think of grimms fairy tales,
you know,
like Little Red Riding Hood where
there's the big bad wolf,
you know,
that is going to eat up little red
riding hood and the 70 stories in
fairytales.
Have wolves that could eat children and
although nowadays the image of wolves
has been sanitized and we're told that
basically a furry loving creatures,
et Cetera,
they are predators and if they get the
chance in the past,
I think they did each children's in the
past,
in the present,
if they have the right numbers.
We know we've talked about this in the
podcast,
but there was an instance in the 14,
hundreds and France were wolves killed
40 people in France.
It's just a matter of them reaching the
right numbers.
World War Two,
there was an instance where the Germans
and the Russians had a ceasefire because
so many of their troops were getting
killed by wolves.
They united together take out a giant
super pack of wolves in Russia because
you know,
there was hundreds of wolves that were
just slaughtering soldiers.
What was.
They're dangerous.
They're.
They're very tricky animals.
Just we eradicated them to very low
numbers and then when the numbers start
to build up again,
they start getting more and more
dangerous again.
But I've seen this myself.
We spend a summers on a remote island in
British Columbia,
Cortez Island BC,
and about 10 years ago the wolves came
back.
They swam from other islands and at
first most people are social liberal
kind of people and so it was great
wildlife returns,
et Cetera.
Um,
but these rules became increasingly bold
and our family and some land up there.
We have a forest,
we don't have a house,
we just have forest land and my sons
without on our land,
they'd been sleeping out when a big wolf
suddenly appeared and looked very,
very threatening and they'd been told,
don't run if you see a wolf.
So they,
they stood there and they faced it and
then it's will sort of puffed up.
It's fair in charged them and it stopped
a few yards away and they backed off
slowly.
They ran when they got around the
corner.
Um,
but this was clearly threatening,
very,
very scary.
Then they started eating people's dogs.
Um,
and there's nothing,
I've never seen a faster transition
from,
uh,
someone who is a kind of wolf,
loving liberal,
won't say dark,
cause heat,
Heaton.
They wanted the guys with guns to come
out and teach these wolves that lesson.
Yeah.
And they did,
some of them were shot and know they're
much more frightened of people.
They keep their distance.
They're still there.
But,
um,
if they,
if there hadn't been a pushback from the
people on the island,
they would have got increasingly bold.
Yeah,
there's an issue that's going on right
now where people are resisting the idea
of hunting walls because they've
reintroduced wolves,
a lot of the western United States.
And uh,
in,
in some places they've reached very
large numbers,
thousands of walls and Idaho and a
couple of these areas where they've
decimated elk and moose,
moose populations or elk and deer
populations rather.
And uh,
you know,
there's a lot of people that are animal
rights folks that aren't there.
They're not there.
And they resist it very strongly.
Like the idea of killing wolves as
barbaric and evil.
But to the folks that lived there,
they're like,
no,
we love animals,
but you have to deal with this.
You've got a real problem here.
Especially when they formed large packs,
they get very dangerous in Russia.
They had these super packs of wolves in
Siberia that we're taking out horses.
They were showing up 100 wolfs at a
time.
They were showing up these horse stables
and slaughtering a horse.
And you know,
there's not much you can do about a
hundred walls.
No.
Well,
given all this background,
I think that's so fascinating for young
children,
especially urban,
young children who've actually never
seen.
They would never see a wolf your life or
any other scary animal.
These are the things that hold their
nightmares.
And I think this is part of a kind of
collective memory.
Um,
I mean the more realistic dangerous for
young children being run over by cars,
a sexual Predator or sexual predators
people.
But that's not what their dreams are.
It may be what their parents nightmares
are about,
but not the children themselves.
So there was a television show in
America that are hosted called fear
factor.
And it was a game show.
They had to do these stunts and
different stents had different things
they have to do.
One of the things that I found
incredibly fascinating with,
some people have irrational fears about
certain animals,
whether it's spiders,
snakes,
a Arachnophobia phobia,
and those,
those fears were undeniable and they
weren't just like,
people are nervous of heights,
like I'm nervous of heights.
I look over the side of a building or
woo,
but it's not an irrational fear.
It's a.
it's a normal natural fear of I don't
want to fall,
but there are some people you would show
them a snake and they would.
They would black out,
they couldn't stay conscious.
They would,
they would hyperventilate and they would
faint.
And I couldn't believe they were normal
folks.
When I would talk to them,
there would be nothing that would
indicate in any way that they were
psychologically deranged or there was
something missing in their,
you know,
whatever developmental period that
they'd gone through,
something got screwed up and they're
just missing a giant chunk of what makes
a person a normal person.
No,
they seem completely normal.
But you show them a spider and they
would,
and I always wondered like what is is
that maybe some someone down the line in
their history was bitten by a spider,
someone down the line was poisoned by a
snake and survived or they saw someone
poisoned by a snake.
I mean,
whatever it is,
it's real and it's a.
These are real psychological issues that
people have to deal with Arachnephobia
in a video phobia in,
in,
in particular,
they're very strong.
Yes.
Well,
I,
I think these could easily be inherited
fairview's.
I mean it's well known in animals that
you can have instinctive fear and of
course it makes sense for animals.
You probably know those experiments they
do with day old chicks or with ducklings
and you have the mountain,
an enclosure doors and then they do
these experiments.
They have cardboard cutouts and with the
silhouettes of birds and you pull them
across on wires and if you pull across
things with the silhouette of a hawk,
these,
these ducklings just freeze.
You know,
the fear response is to just freeze.
They freeze it.
Whereas if you pull across something
looks like silhouette of a pigeon or a
red wing,
black work bad or something,
um,
they don't.
Um,
so they have an inherited fear of things
that could in fact be dangerous and it's
perfectly in terms of evolution.
Makes perfect sense.
See why that would work.
These baby ducklings don't have time to
learn which birds are harmful and which
are not.
But an instinctive response of fear to
something that is actually scary.
It may sometimes lead them to respond
something that isn't like a cardboard
cutout,
but,
um,
it's,
I think these things make complete sense
biologically.
Logically.
Yeah,
it does make sense if you stop and think
about it,
if you really take into consideration
all the things you have to learn to
survive as any animal,
as a,
just this idea that these mice would
learn somehow or another through their,
their parents to avoid that,
that certain smell,
that smell was associated with
electrical shock.
It only makes sense that somehow or
another biological life would transmit
information in as many ways as possible.
Your idea is so fascinating because
you're not even talking about biological
life transferring information through
genetics.
You're talking about it through some
unseen force that has yet to be defined
and that's when things get really
squirrely and is that when you.
That's must be when you experience the
most resistance to these ideas because
the resistance of these ideas,
I'm sure before they proposed this idea
that genetics or that these mice with
somehow or another to inherit the fear
of this smell from their parents.
That was probably not very well received
before it was proven,
but then it was proven so now it's sort
of has to be accepted and has to be
taken into consideration,
but your idea is still very fringe.
Oh yes.
It's.
It's the interesting thing is you see
the response.
I get this from,
from some scientists who is actually
extremely emotional and irrational.
When my first book,
a new science of life came out,
there was a very famous editorial in
nature of the leading science magazine a
few months after the book appeared to
start with.
Nature ignored it,
but then a lot of people got interest.
I was doing programs on the radio in
Britain,
there was an article editorial in the
Guardian saying,
what's an interesting idea?
And so a lot of serious discussion going
on,
New Scientist magazine launched a
competition for the best ideas for
experiments to test morphic resonance
and,
um,
and it was beginning to be widely
discussed,
the editor of nature,
who was a reaction refigure in silence.
So,
you know,
old style materialist mechanistic,
a hardcore scientist wrote a famous
editorial called a book for burning on
the front page of nature.
I'm comparing my book unfavorably with
Mine Kampf Hitler's book,
saying that this was a profoundly
dangerous book.
And he said this is the best candidate
for burning.
There has been for many years and it was
completely irrational.
This attack on my book it emotional,
irrational polemical.
He didn't do it as a joke.
Um,
and this of course produced a backlash
because quite a few scientists thought
this was the wrong way to respond to a
scientific hypothesis.
Um,
so a lot of letters in nature for months
afterwards were backing me up and
saying,
you know,
this is something that should be
seriously discussed,
not simply denounced.
Um,
but the fact is that this started a kind
of controversy which has been going on
ever since.
Um,
but until the year 2000,
most biologists thought genes did
everything.
No,
I'm the epigenetic thing has taken over
in the missing heritability problem.
There's much more openness than the was
because it's clear we haven't figured it
all out.
Interestingly,
Charles Darwin,
um,
was not a neo Darwinian Neo Darwinian
evolution theory says it's all done by
the genes.
Evolution is just about random mutation
and natural selection of gene
frequencies.
This is the basis of Richard Dawkins
work.
For example,
his book,
the selfish gene,
is based on that model.
Darwin,
I'm actually believed in the inheritance
of acquired characteristics.
He thought that animals could inherit
the fears of their fathers and that most
of adaptation could actually be passed
on to animals and plants to send it from
parents.
He thought that was how evolution
worked.
He even proposed that when something had
been learned that could be movement at
something through the bloodstream that
could affect the sperm and the eggs,
exactly the kinds of things that's not
being considered in this fear of the
father's case,
so movement through the bloodstream.
So if you learn something like say if
you touch something,
it's electric fence and it shocks you.
There's movement through the bloodstream
that teaches your sperm.
That was what Darwin thought we put.
He wrote a book called the variation of
animals and plants under domestication
is less well known than his most famous
book,
the origin of species.
Um,
but in the variation of animals and
plants under domestication,
he was so convinced that plants and
animals could inherit what their parents
had learned.
He tried to figure out how it might work
and his last chapter is called the
hypothesis of pathogenesis is the name
he gave to his theory that somehow
little bits were detached from the brain
and went through the blood and affected
the sperm.
No,
that's more or less what people are
saying,
trying to explain the mice,
inheriting the fear of their fathers.
That aspect of Darwin's work has been
airbrushed out of scientific history,
and Darwin also wrote a paper in nature,
um,
about a dog that he came across that
whenever this dog,
uh,
gotten there to a butcher's shop that
the dog was completely terrified.
Butchers and Darwin figured out that
it's parents,
one of his parents had been kicked or
badly mistreated by a butcher,
and this dog had inherited a phobia of
butchers.
Now Darwin published that in nature.
That shows you how very different
Darwin's ideas on evolution were from
his 20th century successors.
And the reason that modern evolutionary
theory is called near Darwinism is to
distinguish it from Darwinism,
which included the inheritance of
habits.
I'm very similar to what I'm saying.
What I'm saying in terms of the
inheritance of habits through morphic
resonance is actually really close to
what Darwin himself said.
Um,
but it's not what neo Darwinians say
because they've tried to say all
inheritances in jeans and you can't have
these other things.
But no,
they'll have to change their tune.
Because as I say in the last few years,
epigenetic inheritance,
the inheritance of acquired
characteristics is back in fashion.
Well,
there's many people that haven't studied
Darwin's ideas at all that aren't
familiar with the amount of resistance
that Darwin received when he was
proposing these ideas,
like these weren't accepted ideas at
all.
In fact,
the majority of scientists at the time
were,
uh,
they were more of a Christian faith
weren't thing.
Yes,
but it was,
the response to Darwin was particularly
interesting.
You see,
because many,
many Christians in England,
um,
after being surprised by his ideas and
actually said,
well,
that's fine if God's the creator of life
and why not,
can't God,
we're a from evolution,
create life that can evolve by Andrea.
It's own steam.
And his ideas were quite rapidly
accepted by the Roman Catholic and
Anglican Episcopal churches and the
methodist and so on.
Um,
this fundamentalist creationist thing is
a peculiar American phenomenon.
It didn't originate until the 20th
century and it was started in America
and it's virtually unknown in Britain.
Um,
I'm actually a practicing Christian.
I'm an Anglican and I never meet
creationists in England.
I've never heard anyone with what
exactly is an Anglican Church of
England.
The Church of England is the,
it's sort of halfway between Protestant
and Catholic.
What happened in England under King
Henry the eighth and the 16th century
was that he nationalized the church and
he said,
okay,
the pope's not head of the church
anymore.
I am and I'm the priest can,
Mary will have services in English and
bishops can be married.
And um,
so,
but the services remain much the same.
And the Church of England,
if you go to Anglican services,
very like a Roman Catholic service,
except that we have married priests,
we have women bishops,
women,
priests,
outrageous,
outrageous from a Catholic point of
view.
Um,
but,
uh,
anyway,
the Church of England is so,
so it's,
it's,
it's never had the sort of extreme
protestant doctrines like southern
baptists and so on.
Um,
it's,
it's very similar to the Catholic
church.
It's now one of the most liberal
churches.
Um,
but Anglicans on the whole had no
problem with evolution.
They still don't.
I've just been doing a workshop last
weekend at the Allen Institute in big
Sur,
which I was co leading with the Bishop
of California,
who's Cathedral is Grace Cathedral in
San Francisco,
a very beautiful cathedral on Nob Hill.
We were discussing the kinds of things
you and I are discussing.
He was completely open to all this.
There was absolutely no problem
discussing this with an Anglican
Episcopalian bishop.
It's a very far cry from what many
people's image of Christians as opposing
evolution,
the general view that many Christians
have.
An I'm one,
um,
is that the evolution of nature of,
if there's a creative part in nature,
it may be God given in the first place,
but what God did was to,
in,
in nature with a part create new forms
of life that there's a kind of
intelligent creativity in nature.
You don't have to have a kind of
intelligent designing engineer outside
nature tinkering with the machinery and
manipulating genes as the intelligent
design people think.
Um,
and uh,
you don't have to deny evolution all
together to say God's involved in nature
in some way.
It's perfectly possible to have a view
where God is in nature and work through
nature,
and there's a creativity in nature which
doesn't require the universe to have
been created in 6,000,
6,000
years ago,
that completely accept the evolutionary
history of the universe and cosmology
and an evolution.
Um,
and just say,
well,
if there's a god,
then that's the way that God works
through this evolutionary process and
through the creativity of evolution.
So,
uh,
the fundamentalist Christians and the
new Earth Christians at that,
that's a uniquely American thing.
Yes.
I mean,
I do have followers,
a few followers in Britain,
but day they take their lead entirely
from America and they've got a new batch
of converts their point of view in the
Islamic world.
Creationism inspired by American
creationist is big in Turkey in many
other Arab countries and stuff.
Um,
but it's a peculiarly American
phenomenon.
We know how it all came about in
America,
right?
Where,
where it really took off.
Well,
it became a part of the political
system.
The Reagan administration,
they started recruiting the radical
Christians and that became a part of his
electoral base.
Yes.
It's a very,
very interesting history.
It had always been,
for most foreigners,
American politics is completely
impossible to understand.
It's impossible to understand how people
can be so polarized and so extreme in
their views.
And I read a book recently which made it
much clearer to me.
It's called the sword of the Lord.
It's written by a guy called Andrew
himes who was raised southern baptist.
Seven of his cousins are southern
Baptist ministers.
His father,
his grandfather,
his grandfather who was called rice,
was one of the inventors of American
fundamentalism and it's a fascinating
historical study of this phenomenon and
why they were like that.
And um,
it made a lot more sense to me.
I mean,
it's still a very bizarre and very
American.
Yeah,
we're,
we're very weird.
Were hard to understand.
Even for us,
we,
you know,
everyone's constantly trying to refocus
our political system or sort of re
redefine it,
calm it down,
reach more.
I mean,
everyone's looking for a more moderate
conservative or someone who is more
conservative,
moderate,
you know,
we're always looking for someone who
meets the bridge,
someone to join the two sides.
So we don't have these radical
polarizing op opposing forces,
the left and the right,
it's just,
it seems so childish.
But what this book made and what was,
for me,
a huge revelation was that how all of
this is rooted in the American civil war
and there's a sense in which in some
people's minds,
the civil war's still going on.
It's just that the sides of switched in
the civil war,
the south was Democrat,
you're the slave owning silence.
They have political party after the
civil war was the Democrats and the
Republicans,
the liberals who wanted to free the
slaves.
And one of the most interesting switches
that's happened is,
is this switch.
So now it's gone the other way around.
The Democrats and other liberals and
stuff.
And uh,
and the Republicans have become the more
right wing forces and powerful in the
south,
which was exactly the opposite.
Very bizarre.
So what this book does is trace the
history of this fascinating movement.
But what's so interesting is it in the
civil war,
both sides were using biblical texts to
justify their position.
But the,
the,
the southern Baptists and the religious
people in the south actually had a much
stronger biblical basis for slavery
because the Bible's full of slaves.
The Old Testament's full of slaves,
the Israelites were slaves themselves.
They owned slaves in the New Testament.
Everyone owned slaves.
It was taken for granted.
There were no abolitionists in the
Bible.
So if you base your faith on the Bible,
you can make a much stronger case for,
for slavery than you can for
abolitionism and so,
but you have to take the Bible is
literally true.
And that gave a strong incentive for
people in the south to make the Bible
literally true.
Because you could justify slavery much
better than if you interpret it in a
liberal way saying,
well actually the spirit of Jesus was to
liberate people from bondage.
They say,
okay,
as well as the text.
Jesus doesn't say anything about
liberating slaves.
So fundamentalism gave a kind of impetus
to this and,
and,
and it was very,
very fascinating to see how that played
out because on both sides in the civil
war,
they were both invoking the Bible that
both sides were Protestant.
Both sites were,
had ministers preaching to inspire the
troops and get them to fight.
And um,
after the civil war,
the way in which this tradition of
fundamentalism that had developed in the
American south justify slavery and gave
a kind of ready made way to use biblical
texts to argue against all sorts of
other things including evolutionary
theory.
Whereas in Europe,
in the traditional Catholic and,
and,
and in the more liberal Protestant
churches,
people hadn't taken the view.
The Bible is the literal truth.
They taken the view that the Bible is a
guide to what might happen.
That a lot of its meaning is allegorical
or symbolic,
but the kinds of so called liberal
interpretation of the Bible goes back to
the second century.
A D or something.
It's,
it's,
it's been the mainstream view for a long
time.
Your scientist,
what,
what leads you to be a practicing
Christian as a scientist?
But I spent years as an atheist.
I mean,
when I was educated as a scientist,
part of the package deal is acs.
You know,
I grew up with all the standard time is
14.
I was at a religious boarding school,
a Christian boarding school.
I was the only boy in my year who
refused to get confirmed because even at
14 identified as an atheist.
Um,
and I thought science means science and
reason,
religion and superstition of things that
the past two scientists at the vanguard
of human progress,
all that kind of thing.
I believe that.
But what made me begin to doubt it was I
began to doubt that this was the right
way forward in science.
Um,
I began to think that this mechanistic
molecular approach to treating animals
and plants as just machines,
uh,
was an inadequate view of life.
I'd gone into biology because I was
fascinated by animals and plants.
I kept lots of pets as a child.
My father was a herbalist.
I collected plants and he taught me
about plants.
He had a microscope,
love oratory and cyber source of really
got into science as a child.
Um,
and uh,
when I started studying science at
school and university,
the first thing we did with living
organisms,
organisms was to kill them and grind
them up and then look at the enzymes in
the liver or whatever.
Um,
it became clear to me,
we've not really studying life.
We were studying death.
Um,
and when I was a child I kept homing
pigeons and I was fascinated with how do
they find their home.
I asked everybody I knew,
man,
who kept homing pigeons.
It was a popular sport in Britain.
It still is.
Um,
I had some myself and I used to put them
in a box and cyclist fun as I could on
my bicycle and released them and then
cycle home and they always got home
before I did a.
However far I took them out.
So this completely intrigued me and I
thought,
we're never going to understand this by
just grinding up their livers or looking
at their genes.
So I began to doubt the mechanistic
world view.
Um,
then,
um,
I encountered psychedelics and that was
a huge change,
I mean nothing in my scientific
education and prepared me for the kind
of mind opening effects of LSD and this
was in the seventies,
early seventies.
Um,
and um,
you know,
I'd studied nerve impulses and hormones
and that kind of thing,
which is what we got in a science course
at Cambridge about the brain and you
know,
I knew about the international youth,
the brain and nerve impulses,
but these visionary experiences that
psychedelics opened up showed me there
was far more to the mind and indeed far
more to reality than there's very,
very limited model.
Then I got interested in meditation
because I thought,
well,
it'd be good to be able to explore the
mind without drugs.
I mean I'm not anti psychedelic tour,
but it'd be good to have different
methods,
not just drugs.
And then I took up transcendental
meditation and Yoga and then I got a job
in India.
I lived in India for seven years and
when I was in India I was really into
yoga and meditation.
And,
and at first I thought,
this is just changing my brain
physiology,
you don't need to believe there's a god
out there or any thing mysterious out
there.
It's just inside the body,
the chemicals of the brain,
the yoga and meditation affect blood
flow,
et cetera.
So I saw it in rather materialistic way,
but then I got more and more interest in
Hindu philosophy,
in Hindu ideas,
the idea that there's a greater
consciousness within which our
consciousness is embedded through
something,
through some psychedelic experiences.
We Ca,
we contact other realms of consciousness
that aren't just inside our brains
through meditation and through prayer
that one can actually contact other
forms of consciousness bigger than our
own.
I did all that within a kind of Hindu
context.
And then I had a Sufi teacher in India
as well,
so I did sort of Islamic mysticism for
awhile.
But after doing this for several years,
I found that actually some of it didn't
make sense to me.
The part that doesn't,
didn't make sense to me.
Well,
the Islamic part to be a Sufi in India,
basically you had to be a Muslim and I
didn't really want to get into being a
Muslim and sort of fasting in Ramadan
and all that to be and Hindus.
They're basic worldview walls and for
most of them still is the idea that
we're just trapped in a world where
things go on and on.
Rebirth and cycles of life and death and
we're trapped in this world of suffering
and delusion and the way out is through
a kind of spiritual vertical takeoff
which you do individually through
meditation.
You can liberate yourself from
reincarnation and delusion and so forth
into absorption in the one and the
absolute.
But it's an individual vertical takeoff.
And I was working in an agricultural
institute,
the main International Institute in
India for trying to improve crops for
poor farmers.
And sometimes my Indian colleagues would
say to me after work,
we always say,
why do you do this?
And I'd say,
because you know,
I want to help these poor people and you
know,
they haven't got enough to eat it.
Be Great.
If they had better farming methods.
And improve for artists and science can
help,
and I believe in trying to apply my
knowledge to help these people.
And he said,
it is none of your business.
It,
they are poor.
If they are suffering,
it is that cardamom.
It is not your business.
It is their problem,
not your problem.
Your problem is to liberate yourself
from this world of illusion.
So then I realized actually they have a
completely different view that it's the
poor suffering because in a sense they
deserve to suffer because of what
they've done in past lives.
Nothing I can do about it.
Then I realized actually I do care about
other people.
I do think that a spiritual life is not
just about individual liberation.
It's to do with collective things,
is to do it affects community.
And how can other people be helped?
Unless I argued with my Hindu friends.
I realized the reason I was saying this
is because I'm so deeply embedded in the
Christian tradition.
Even secular humanism is a kind of
secularized Christianity because it's
about helping others.
Uh,
that actually,
um,
I was much more Christian than I
actually had ever admitted.
So I was confirmed in the Church of
south India and I then found a fantastic
ashram where I lived for two years,
father bede griffiths,
who is an English Benedictine now to
Christian Ashram in south India,
which was exactly to my taste.
It was very simple.
We did yoga,
we did meditation.
Um,
we,
uh,
we had Christian services and we sang
Indian chants and curtains and things.
It didn't try and deny any of this.
And when I first went there,
we started the mass with the gaietry
mantra,
which is a Hindu mantra,
asking the sun to bless our meditation,
the divine splendor of the sun to
illuminate our meditation.
So I said to father bede when I first
went there,
now how can you have the gaietry mantra
at the beginning of a Catholic service?
And he said,
precisely because it's Catholic,
he said Catholic means universal.
If it excludes anything,
which is a path to God,
then it's just sectarian.
The word Catholic means universal.
Yes.
That's what he's fascinating.
So,
um,
uh,
so I found a way of being Christian
which didn't Deny Yoga,
meditation,
Buddhism,
my wife has a practicing Tibetan
Buddhist,
she follows us.
I'll Chen tradition in Tibetan Buddhism.
So I found a way of reconnecting with
the Christian tradition which didn't
violate my sense of reason.
It didn't conflict with the kind of
science that I'm interested in,
but I found it liberating to reconnect.
And so when I went back to England from
India,
um,
I was able to go to those great
cathedrals that we have in England.
Belt in the middle ages is fantastic
buildings,
stained glass,
wonderful music organs playing amazing
choirs,
singing the most beautiful music and,
and feel that this is not just beautiful
but meaningful and as a,
as a path to God which had not seen
before.
That's fascinating.
So in India,
the concept of Karma being that someone
has done something in their past life
that's led them to where they are right
now,
that boy that seems real convenient for
someone passing by homeless people or
someone who's poor or suffering.
It's almost like the numbers of people
that they have in India.
Because the numbers are so great,
a billion people.
How much bigger is India than in North
America?
Oh,
the size of the land.
As much smaller.
The population is almost a billion.
How much smaller is the size of the
land?
I don't know,
but it's crazy.
I wonder if that came about as just a
way of mitigating the pressure of
helping people.
Like just the idea of Karma.
You can't help that guy.
That's his problem.
You gotta do it yourself.
Just the sheer numbers.
Like what I do.
I mean at the time the British were
ruling India.
There are only about 200 million and
when I was born the robot to 50 million
when you were born.
I was born in 1942.
They did a lot of huge,
huge increase increase.
Wow.
Anyway,
the thing is about the convenience.
The Karma thing in India uses.
It is convenient.
For for centuries India's had a caste
system.
The untouchables are treated like dirt.
I mean they're considered to be
polluting and dirty.
Even if the shadow of an untouchable
fell on the brahmins house,
this person could be punished very
various severity and there was no move
within India until the 19th century to
reform that.
What happened with Christian
missionaries went there.
They were nice to untouchables and to
lower costs and,
and it gave them food,
education,
healthcare,
et cetera.
And some of them became Christians.
I mean,
why not?
If you're at the bottom of the pile,
you've not got anything to lose and
you've got a lot to gain by becoming a
Christian.
So Hindu reformers felt that they had
contractors and so things like the
Ramakrishna mission and Sri Aurobindo
and various Hindu philosophers and Gandy
himself,
uh,
who was a big influence in India,
assimilated many of these ideas from
Christianity and said,
look,
we've got to reform hinduism.
And they created a new kind of Hindu
attitude,
much influenced by Christianity.
And so there are no Indian movements to
try and help the poor and no provide
health care for the sick and that kind
of thing.
But that's not been part of their
traditional way of doing things.
And it came about under Western
influence.
That's really fascinating.
So your desire to sort of help help
these people,
help them grow more food and help help
them live better lives is what led you
to become a Christian.
You realize that these are Christian
ideas?
Yes.
That they are Christian.
They're deeply embedded in our culture.
Even for secular humanists,
you see St Louis humanness,
so usually atheists who believe in a
philosophy of equal rights,
equal opportunities in helping the poor
and the sick education for those who
need know for,
for,
for everyone.
And um,
uplifting people who are suffering,
helping third world countries have
running water and all that kind of
thing.
Well,
these are the things that Christian
missionaries have done as well,
but you don't have to be a Christian to
believe in those things,
but the fact that they are so deeply
embedded in our culture,
uh,
in our secular culture is because of the
influence historically influence of
Christianity.
So secular humanists are basically
people who still have Christian ethics,
but without a belief in God.
But that ethical system doesn't just
come about automatically.
A much more default mode is to say,
you know,
the strong miters,
right,
the,
you know,
the strongest guy gets the girls and,
and you know,
runs a kind of theme and then conquer
people and have slaves.
That's how humanities worked for much of
human history.
Yeah.
It,
most certainly has.
So this,
it sounds like you found a very cool
sect of Christianity while you were in
India.
I mean,
that sounds very unique that you were
doing yoga and meditation and then these
Indian chants all along with this
concept of Christianity being like the,
the generosity and the helping your
brothers and sisters along with that
seems to be like that.
That must have been very convenient to
find that sect of Christianity while you
were sort of exploring these ideas.
It wasn't even the sect.
Griffis was a benedictine monk and he
was a Roman Catholic.
Now it's true that some people in the
Catholic Church didn't approve of what
he was doing,
but,
uh,
so it was really just him.
It was well here,
Amanda Group of other people.
I mean,
there was a whole movement in,
in India of Catholics too.
It was called inculturation.
It was the second Vatican council in the
19 sixties,
uh,
said that what people should do in the
Catholic church is put the Christian
faith into the terms of that culture.
So in India,
Catholics who have been converted by
Catholic missionaries from Ireland and
places,
um,
bought pairs of shoes so he can put them
on to go to church on Sundays because
the mission is dressed in western
clothes and wore shoes in church.
These Indians would never wear shoes and
a temple or a mosque or even in the
house,
but they will choose in church because
that's what the Catholic missionaries
wall,
that kind of thing is ridiculous.
And so the simplest level,
the incarceration movement,
we say,
well,
it's the tradition of injuries.
Take your shoes off in homes and in
temples,
in marks.
So you take them off in churches tune.
And it was the tradition of Holy Men and
women in Nto to be vegetarian.
Whereas Catholics and Protestants,
they're all eating lots of beef and
stuff because that's what American and
British missionaries at.
Um,
and so they said,
no,
it's much more natural to be vegetarian.
You don't have to be,
but it's more natural.
So this idea of yoga is a way of
learning how to breathe and to challenge
and to be more healthy.
Why shouldn't Indian Christians do yoga?
Right?
So this is part of a movement.
Father Bede was part of a wider
movement.
The last two popes had been rather
reactionary and you've tried to roll
back that movement,
but there are still people in India,
in South America and so on who are
following this Vatican second Vatican
Council reform movement,
or the new pope is fairly unique.
His name,
he seems to be a or a much less
polarizing figure.
He seems to be much more generous,
much more open minded to the idea of
homosexuality to a lot of the things
that have been criticized in the past.
And he also like he's showing the ideas
of monetary wealth.
He doesn't have that crazy thrown
anymore.
He has a reasonable chair.
He's a,
he's a unique guy.
I think it's partly because he comes
from South America,
you see and do this kind of radical
Catholic movement.
The Second Vatican Council Liberation
Theology,
which was about the church should be,
they're not serve the rich but to help
the poor.
And this became a huge movement in South
America.
Um,
but uh,
the,
the previous Pope John Paul,
the second was against it because he,
they were teaming up with communists and
people who are also trying to help the
poor for secular reasons and political
reasons,
not for Christian reasons.
So he said this is wrong because it
communistic,
but actually that movement,
there's this radical Catholic movements
had a huge influence in South America.
And I think the present pope is somebody
who's come out
of that world who's been very much
influenced by it.
It's so problematic though.
The suppressing his sexuality like that.
The number one thing that people
associate Catholicism width is sexual
assault is sexually molesting children.
That's like a huge aspect.
I grew up a Catholic.
I was only in,
I was a practicing Catholic when I was
very young.
I went to a Catholic school in New
Jersey for first grade and it was a very
bad schools,
like really dark and suppressing,
just very nasty and mean,
and the nuns were just horrific people
and essentially shied me away from all
religion at a very young age before
then.
Yeah,
it was terrible.
It was terrible.
But I have other friends that were also
raised Catholic that literally had to
fight off the priests sexual attempts
and that this is like a standard thing.
If it's a joke,
it's an on running joke in America about
priests being sexual predators.
It's a constant thing.
Um,
that,
that seems to me like one of the number
one issues with that particular brand of
religion.
It's like this idea that you're gonna
take what is essentially just a natural
part of being a human being.
You're not doing anything with the
reproductive cycle.
You're just telling them to ignore it.
You have this consistent,
constant bodily function.
There's your body's reproducing fluids
on a regular basis and you living backed
up all the time.
And also you're not experiencing any
romantic interaction with human beings.
No.
No affection,
no sexual affection,
no nothing,
no,
you're missing out on a huge part of
what it is to be a person.
And these people grow up and they live
cradle to the grave in this sort of
weird non developed state.
You know,
they're not like the rest of the people.
They can barely even understand.
Like I had a friend that went to
marriage counseling with a Catholic
priest.
I'm my.
That's hilarious.
That's like going to Hitler and,
uh,
asking how to have world peace and maybe
it doesn't make any sense.
Like,
what do you,
how are you going to a guy who not only
does not have any sex,
has never had a relationship but is
drunk all the time.
He had gin blossoms all over his face
and kids run away from them because
they're afraid it's going to touch them
and you're going to go to that guy and
he's going to give you marriage advice.
I agree.
I think it's a terrible thing and I mean
there are a lot of good priests who
don't do this.
And I met quite a few windows in India
and I have reverend Catholic priests
whose friends and so I think it's a
minority.
It may have been quite a big minority in
Ireland and in some countries,
but I think it was a,
some people are called to a celibate
life and,
and I think that's fine for people to
get become monks or nuns if that's what
they're called to.
But for regular priests,
I think it's a serious mistake.
And I'm
in the Church of England ever since 15,
40 or something and in the process and
churches in Europe,
priests have been able to marry and
rabbis Mary in Judaism and I think is
much,
much healthier to have priests as
regular guys.
We love lives and kids and things.
So I think that side of Catholicism is a
serious mistake and I think they should
do it.
Sooner or later it'll have to be
reformed because repression of sexuality
leads to all these extremely unhealthy.
A negative consequences.
No,
I agree with you about it.
But you know,
there are reform movements within
Catholicism and uh,
they're in America.
They're a breakaway Catholic.
Churches with women priests for example,
there's one in Santa Barbara and of
course it's in Santa Barbara,
freaks up.
They're loaded.
So,
um,
this,
anyway,
I agree with you.
I think that's a very negative thing,
but you see,
I think that to,
to reject the entire,
some people reject the entire world of
religion because of personal bad
experiences with one particular brand.
I think it's rather like throwing out
the baby with the bath water.
It would be like saying I'm against
science because it gave us gas that
kittle used to kill people and it gave
us the atomic bomb that killed people in
Hiroshima.
So I'm against science.
I mean science,
everything,
human,
uh,
there are really bad things that have
been done by humans in the name of
almost anything you care to mention.
Nationalism,
science,
religion,
politics,
ideology.
So when you decided to join this
particular group of Christians and
become a Christian,
officially identify,
was there resistance from your
colleagues?
Reserve resistance from other
scientists?
Like how old were you at the time?
Oh,
I was 33,
something like that.
Um,
well,
not among.
I was working in India at the time.
There's hardly any acs in India.
There's a few,
but among my scientific colleagues,
I was working with Indian scientists.
Almost all Indians are Hindu,
Hindu or Muslim,
you know,
when they went home from work,
they'd be regular Hindus and Muslims
there.
Very few of them were atheists.
So I'm among my Indian colleagues.
Being a practicing Christian when I came
from a Christian family in a Christian
country seemed totally normal.
No one thought that was at all weird or
strange when I got back to England.
I'm among many of my scientific friends.
Um,
they thought this was completely weird
and um,
and just couldn't understand it because
they assume that any Christian believes
the world's made in 6,000
years ago and God intervenes through
suspending the laws of nature in
miracles that are totally incredible and
they don't believe in the kind of God I
don't believe in.
Um,
but they never actually,
very few ever asked what do you actually
think or believe?
They just sort of treated it as best as
some kind of personal eccentricity or
mental feebleness or something.
Um,
and while retaining,
rather than narrow dogmatically atheist
view,
I lot of my friends are atheists or
agnostics,
but the problem I have with atheists and
materialists is that most of them are
much more dogmatic than the people I
know within the religious world.
Well,
I have a problem with anybody that's
sure.
So do I.
Yes.
Uh,
when,
when I speak to some atheists,
I have this issue where they're
aggressively atheist,
you know,
where you know,
uh,
I've,
I've talked to people who the,
they're not just atheist,
but they get upset at anyone who's not.
And my question to them is always like,
have you ever had a psychedelic
experience?
Whenever I speak with someone who's
aggressively atheists,
and if they say no,
I'm like,
well,
what are you waiting for?
Because if you,
if you really want to question your,
your whole idea of reality,
there's no better method than a
breakthrough psychedelic experience.
If you have a breakthrough psychedelic
experience and you're like,
that was nothing,
well then you're a unique person because
everybody I've ever met that has a
breakthrough psychedelic experience,
like a dmt trip.
They have to step back and go,
okay,
I didn't even know that was possible.
I've lived my whole life with this one
worldview that,
well,
I see these people that are religious
and it seems to me that they're
following this ridiculous ideology is
based on some ancient information that
people wrote down on animal skins.
It's all preposterous and what they're
doing is they're just a bunch of scared
children that are afraid of the light
and what I'm doing is basing my life on
science and rational thinking and logic,
but then you have a psychedelic trip and
he's like,
there's nothing rational about that.
There's nothing logical about that and
how's that so close?
It's so nearby.
It's like someone telling you a dmt trip
is like someone telling you,
Hey,
I want to show you something.
Let's go into this room real quick,
and you opened that door and there's a
new universe.
They're a completely different universe
that's filled with life.
It's fractal.
It's never ending and it occupies a very
small space,
but yet it's infinite and it's filled
with conscious beings that can see
through you.
Recognize all your bullshit.
Recognize all your insecurities and all
your incorrect thinking and ego and and,
and they try to and then you shut the
door and you go back to regular life and
you're like,
what the fuck is that room?
That room?
That's the God room.
It's right there.
Like if you don't go into that
experience like your whole,
like I think we live our lives based on.
We sort of calculate our worldview based
on the experiences that we've
accumulated,
what we've learned from these
experiences and what we've learned from
other people's experiences,
what we've read,
what we've seen in documentaries and
films,
but when you have a really intense
psychedelic experience particularly,
and then for some people yoga and
meditation,
some people are able to achieve some
pretty deep states,
but the psychedelic experience in
particular is.
It's shocking because it's so easy to
get to.
It's just right there.
Four hits of the DMT and boom blast off
and then 15 minutes later you're left
with this new experience that you have
to assimilate and figure out a way to
make sense of it.
The atheist and I talked to that are
like super aggressive.
They're just like religious people,
people and a lot of ways it's kind of
scientific fundamentalism and it's.
It's also morphing now know if you're
aware of this.
In America it's morphing,
there's atheism and then there's an even
more aggressive group called atheism
plus.
Oh,
I didn't know about that.
Yeah,
and what they're doing is they're
attaching a bunch of moral and ethical
values to religion essentially creating
almost like another religion and I think
with good intentions,
I think a lot of his good intentions a
lot of is based on.
A lot of it is based on feminism.
A lot of is based on the idea of
avoiding harassment,
avoiding sexual harassment,
avoiding like that.
They their ethics are to completely
define what's acceptable behavior like
no,
no racism,
no sexual harassment,
no undeniable acceptance of women's
rights.
Undeniable acceptance of.
It's interesting,
but then of course once you define that,
then you have a aggressive members of
that group that are attacking people
that disagree with any of their
propositions or anyone that supports
men's rights.
Of course now he hates women and you get
a lot of weirdness in that area because
they can only be feminism,
that can't be men's rights as well,
men's rights or toxic,
whereas women's rights,
once there is a cheat,
once they have achieved a totally
quality,
then there's no need for men's rights
because once feminism has been
established,
which is pretty illogical assumption,
especially when you consider like
divorce laws.
No,
I agree with you.
I couldn't agree more about DMT and,
and the,
the opening that it can give.
I mean I had the great advantage of
taking it for the first time with
Terence Mckenna and he was,
he said,
do you want to check this out?
Okay.
And that's pretty cool.
And the resume,
by the way,
first time you did DMT,
Terence Mckenna?
Yes.
I won't say where or when,
because it could be put down on some
record somewhere that's probably already
there.
Don't worry about it.
Um,
but um,
for me it corresponded in many ways with
what people talk about near death
experiences because I went out through
light into a realm of great bliss and
beauty.
And then I came back and it was like
coming back from a million miles away
and just coming back into my body and as
it were being born again.
Um,
so it was,
it was very much like a death and
rebirth experience for me.
And,
and it was very,
very transformative.
Um,
incidentally,
I think,
you know,
I've been trying to understand this
American phenomena with southern
baptists.
And one of the things that I think is
the key to this is that I think when
they talk about being born again,
originally baptism was just that.
I mean now you can get this through dmt
in five minutes,
but at the time of John The baptist,
you get it in five minutes through being
drowned.
People were lining up on the bank of the
Jordan.
They go in,
he holds them under.
If he held him under just long enough,
you could actually induce a near death
experience.
New Life Review at the drowning man sees
his life pass before him hold the amount
of just long enough.
And they'd have a near death experience
almost guaranteed.
I mean,
occasionally they might,
he might have done it too long,
but that was before litigation.
You know,
you might've lost.
Yeah,
good theory actually.
Then you see they come back and they
said,
I've died.
I've seen the light.
I've been born again.
I'm no longer afraid of death.
My life has been transformed in five
minutes and the baptists were the people
who revived baptism by total immersion
in the 16th century and probably no in
in America.
We don't hold them under that long
because this is post litigation now,
but you know when,
when the Baptist first got going,
this idea of holding people aren't long
enough.
All their language is the language that
relates to near death experiences and I
don't think that to start with baptism
by total immersion was just symbolic.
I think it was drowning.
Wow.
That is quite fascinating and it makes
sense.
If you think about ordeal poisoning or
deal poisoning being the substitute for
psychedelics in certain cultures where
they don't have access to psychedelic
plants,
they would take essentially a poison
that didn't kill you.
It got you right to the door where you
wish you were dead almost.
You were in horrible pain and even in
some cultures they use ant venom like
those bullet ants,
the.
They use that for these ritualistic a
coming of age rituals,
these coming of age rituals where you
take people through these intensely
painful moments where they almost want
to be dead just to end the suffering and
then when they come through and the
other side,
there are a better person because of it.
They're more reflective.
They're sort of there.
They appreciate that.
Just the very breath that they're
allowed to take.
They appreciate the sky seems bluer.
The grass seems greener.
The life has more vibrancy to it because
they've gone through this ordeal.
Poison or these toxic venom or what have
you.
Yes,
a right of passage.
Almost all rites
of passage for adolescents in,
in,
in traditional cultures involved
something like a death and rebirth
experience and I think you're right.
I think that's what's going on and
actually I think that the why the
Baptist became so powerful and why for
them the conversion experience was so
real and why they talk about it so much
is that because for many of them it was
real.
It wasn't just a symbolic thing.
It wasn't signing up to some set of
beliefs and I think this is the core of
all religions is this direct experience
of the divine and you know,
I think that's what they all come from.
They come from experience,
not theories.
What's quite
shocking to that.
Jerusalem scholars like may like
mainstream scholars now or considering
that Moses was probably under the
influence of DMT.
They believed that the burning Bush,
there's,
you know,
guys are not like psychedelically based
at all,
was quite probably the Acacia Bush,
which was a very rich in dmt plant and
that's the whole idea of the burning
Bush.
He sees God through a burning Bush.
I mean,
how much clear does it have to be?
There's acacia trees all over that.
That part of the world.
It says very rich plant as far as the
content of DMT in it and if you
experience that,
it's very much like.
I mean,
I don't know if you're experiencing God,
but it seems like it seems very divine
when you have a dmt trip.
Yes.
Well,
I mean why not be experiencing God?
I mean,
it seems unlike.
It seems non economical theory to say
that this divine bliss as experienced by
mystics,
that part of the nature of mind is
bliss.
I mean the Hindu name,
one of the names sachit and ended up
being knowledge place as in the nature
of God.
If God's consciousness is kind of
blessed consciousness,
then if you have this experience that
seems like garden is blissful,
why have a hypothesis that that some
other bliss consciousness that isn't
divine,
that some kind of duplicate,
why not?
It'd be the real thing.
I think it makes so much more sense.
Yeah,
totally makes sense.
I mean it,
it makes as much sense as anything else
and these plants are real.
I've always wondered if that and many
other people speculator as well,
if that's the reason why Hindus don't
participate in eating cows too because
of the psilocybin mushrooms growing on
cows on a regular basis and that being
for a lot of people believe that basis
Soma.
I don't know.
It's,
it's,
I'm don't terrence's theory about Strip
area and these mushrooms growing on car
dung is okay as far as it goes.
But in England,
for example,
the,
the magic mushroom,
the liberty cap doesn't grow on car
dying at grows in sort of meadows and
usually no carson if anything,
the sheep,
but I've seen them.
They grow wild in Wales and I've
encountered them on location and there's
nothing to do with piles of Dung.
I mean there's many different
environments in which psychoactive
mushrooms grow.
Some kinds rely on the car done,
but I think he rather over emphasize the
car dunk.
That's fascinating.
What do you think was the source of
cattle worship like Chuck Tall Oak and
all these ancient civilizations that
worship cattle and this connection that
Mckenna made with,
uh,
those,
those people worshiping the capital
because the cattle didn't just provide
life and food because they had milk and
meat,
but also that there was this connection
with a psychedelic mushrooms.
I take now,
I find that a bit far fetched personally
in some countries like in England and
Oh,
there was a whole sweatshop in the cage.
There was a whole sweatshop sacred
horses too.
And um,
there,
there are many different kinds of sacred
animal even in India is not just caused
the to sacred elephants are sacred.
Ganesh shoes,
you know,
the elephant God.
But elephants are sacred.
Even rats are sacred.
I'm in India and monkeys,
so lots.
There's lots of sacred animals.
Um,
and I think that probably come,
I think with the ones that are wild,
basically wild like elephants and rats
and monkeys.
There's probably comes out to shamanic
roots,
but I think when people started
domesticating animals then know,
how do you relate to domesticated
animals?
Are they like slaves or are they the cow
is seen by most induces the divine
mother,
the provider of milk.
And do you regard them as sacred or do
you just regard them as cogs in a
factory farming machine?
Well,
that's the way they are regarded now in
feed lots and so on,
in the United States and in Europe.
Um,
but I think in a religious culture when
you domesticate animals,
there's a sense in which they take on a
religious significance.
And,
um,
you know,
for,
for the Jewish people,
then goats and sheep were the main ones
that took on the religious significance.
You know,
Jesus Lamb of God that takes away the
sins of the world.
The Agnes de,
um,
this is a sacrificial lamb which is a
sort of sacred lamb.
And so there's a synchronization of
sheep in the Judaic Christian,
in the Islamic tradition.
It completely makes sense that people
would worship cows and even horses
because they need the horses for
transportation.
Um,
you know,
in a lot of cultures they even used
horses to stay alive.
Like they drank the blood of the horses.
That was a big thing with the Mongols.
It's one of the reasons why they.
They brought like you know each.
Each man had many horses that they would
carry with them and they would mix it
with milk and it would be a way to stay
alive.
May or may would take the blood of a
certain horses,
the milk of other ones and all that.
Makes Sense.
What I've always wondered those,
how did they,
how did they lose the meaning of Soma?
Like how do,
how is that such a,
an open thing?
Open interpretation.
I mean what?
What happened to if it was such an
amazing thing.
I mean you read the descriptions of
Salma,
how fantastic it is and how huge a part
of it.
It wasn't their culture and their
connection to the divine.
How did they lose what it means,
but I agree.
I think it's a mystery and it's seminary
increased the Eleusinian mysteries.
This cave where they went in these
psychedelic rites of passage that Plato
and people here.
There was a big part of life in ancient
Greece.
What was that and the,
the,
the most commentaries ones where people
see it as Amnesia,
Mascara,
the flyer,
garrick.
I've never found those particularly
plausible because whenever I've taken
flyer garrick where he wants so twice,
all it did was give me a headache and
um,
it's maybe they had different varieties
of it,
but I don't know anyone who's had a
totally amazing flyer,
garrick trip.
I've only spoken to people online that
have,
I've,
I've only had it once and I felt the
same way.
It didn't do anything for me.
I,
I don't know if it enhanced,
but I did it and then we did it for a
couple hours and it didn't seem to have
any effect.
And then we took psilocybin after that
and it had a huge effect.
It was just a monster trip.
And I wonder if it was some sort of a
common atory experience.
Possibly.
But that was another thing that Mckenna
speculated about,
whether it was variable genetically
variable seasonably variable.
As far as geographically,
yes.
And whether it's transformed like
reindeer and transformed by the rain and
then where they drink the urine of
reindeer after the reindeer of eastern
yet and stuff.
Right.
And the laps and people.
Well,
it's also the,
all the different connections to the
Siberian shamans and that the whole
Christmas thing,
the whole connection to Christmas and
the Amanita miscarrying mushroom.
It's very,
very bizarre that elves are connected
with this particular mushroom which is
connected with Christmas and gifts.
And yes,
symbiotic relationship to carnivorous
trees.
Like the whole deal.
It is,
it's mysterious.
But yeah,
I've never found that area of
speculation particularly satisfying.
I mean if,
if,
if the evidence pointed towards Strip
area cubensis or psilocybe semi
Lanceolata United Liberty Cap or our
native psychedelic mushroom in England,
then it might be more convincing.
Right.
I mean,
the fact is we don't know.
And it's really a matter of speculation.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's like,
you know,
like heirloom tomatoes,
you eat an heirloom tomato,
they're so delicious.
They're fantastic,
they're sweet,
they're,
they,
they're so rich and dark.
Or you can get one of these creepy
tomatoes that they grow that live like
the last,
like a month on a shelf and they're pale
and they're hard and they just taste
like shit.
I mean,
there's nothing to them like they.
They look different,
they taste different.
I wonder if that somehow or another
happened to the am anita where it lost
it's psychedelic properties.
Unlikely because never been cultivated
and grows in the wild
would be maybe just the temperature
variations like that.
Maybe you have to have it in that
incredibly cold environment of Siberia
for it to be that it's geographically
genetically variable.
Oh,
what you said makes the most sense to me
that it was mixed with something else.
It's like Oscar,
if you just took one of the components
of the brew,
if the historical data pointed worlds,
this being there,
you'd say,
okay,
this is what it was,
but actually neither of the components
would work on their own.
So it may well have been that it was
part of a mixture
that does kind of make sense for Salma.
Right?
Because wasn't so much actually.
It was described as some sort of
next year,
and so it was the Eleusinian mysteries.
You just don't know what the Eleusinian
mysteries are.
Huh?
There.
Is there any speculation?
Oh,
Graham Hancock have speculations of
course,
but I don't know.
The ones I've seen would include opium
in cannabis as part of the mix.
I mean,
cannabis was widely known in the ancient
world and actual hemp ropes were used
for thousands of years.
People were growing.
Hemp.
Opium has been known for an awfully long
time.
Um,
so what else might have been in there?
We don't know.
Well,
that's the other thing too.
The,
the consumption,
the eating of cannabis,
uh,
eating of Hash has produced incredible
psychedelic experiences for people.
They've eaten large enough quantities
where it's been very mushroom,
like
much more psychogenic when Easton,
and it's traditional to take it by mouth
in India as well as to smoke it.
I mean,
it's a normal thing that the festival of
Holy h o n I a major Hindu festival when
I was living in India,
I was renting a wing of a crumbling
palace and hydropower from a family of
impoverished rogers.
And they were very respectable,
or they're impoverished and and on holy.
This festival day,
the Roger's wife,
the Ronnie came to me and she said,
Dr Saab,
you must take our special drink.
She said,
this is our special drink for holy and
stuff.
And I said,
what is it?
She said,
Oh,
I will tell you later.
She says,
she's like the Joey Diaz of India,
those two up.
So I just drank.
This is bang.
Then she said,
have some more and say,
and various stoned with his bang this
drink cannabis containing drink.
And then everyone's sort of rushing
around throwing colored water at each
other.
But I mean this was a highly
respectable,
conservative,
Brahmin family and this was just part of
their traditional way of life and,
and in,
in,
in the,
in the drunk form.
Wow.
In the liquid,
the edible form.
That's,
that's quite amazing.
I mean,
I,
I often wonder how much different our
worldview would be if we had those sorts
of traditions here in America because
that's traditions and just sort of these
cultural norms that we accept.
They shaped so much of our behavior.
They shaped so much of how we view the
world and so much of it is just based on
momentum.
It's just based on what did your
grandparents do,
what did they teach your parents and
what did your parents teach you and what
is the collective culture of your
neighborhood?
Your community?
Yes,
exactly.
One thing that's just occurred to me,
well,
there's two things I'd like to ask you.
Well,
one thing,
let me ask you something,
please does.
You know I've done a lot of research on
the sense of being stared at and I think
that this feeling that almost everyone's
experienced feeling,
you're being looked at your turn around
someone's staring at you or you can
stare at someone and make them turn
around and this is something which is
very widespread in the population.
There's been a kind of scientific to bu
for years about it because it ought not
happen.
If your mind is nothing but your brain
looking at someone shouldn't effect them
because everything is all inside your
head.
Whereas if when you look at somebody,
the image that you're seeing is
projected out as I suggested,
is that when I look at you now,
I don't think you're my imagery view in
three dimensions and full color is
inside my head.
I think it's where you are.
I think I'm projecting out my image
review.
Everything I'm seeing in this room is
where it seems to be projected out.
My Mind's extended beyond my brain
anyway.
That is how we experience it.
The official theories.
It's all inside the head.
Um,
and because the official theory says
this is just a superstition and people
can't really tell them they're being
looked at the been almost no scientific
investigation till I took it up in the
19 eighties and now quite a number of
people have done this research on the
sense of being stared at to find out if
people really can tell when they're
being stared out from behind.
Um,
I've done lots of experiments in
schools.
Kids are particularly sensitive to this
more so than grownups.
Really?
Yes.
And I then to find out,
but I thought,
well look,
I've done the experiments,
but who are the professionals?
So I,
in my research assistant interviewed
security guards,
store detectives to drug squad at
Heathrow,
uh,
police,
and private detectives,
you know,
have you ever had this experience?
Do people know when they're being
watched?
Almost everyone who watches others for
living such,
of course they do.
And you know,
if you're being trained to be a private
detective trained how to follow
somebody,
you don't stare at their back because
they're likely to turn around and catch
your eye.
So anyway,
I wrote about this in my book,
the sense of being stared at about this
research and about its implications for
the nature of our minds.
But I had recently somebody came to me
from a British defense research
laboratory and he said to me,
they've got very interested in this,
uh,
in the army because there's some
generals that worried that British
troops in Afghanistan.
And I was so laden down with kit,
you know,
gps systems.
I mean,
that whole body is covered with
electronic kit.
And they found that when they're so top
heavy carrying all this kit,
they have to look down at the ground all
the time to avoid stumbling because it's
harder to walk with all this stuff and
they can easily be picked off by
guerrilla fighters behind rocks with
rifles.
And so what they said is,
do you think we could train people in
threat awareness so they could actually
become more sensitive now in the martial
arts,
I know some martial arts do have threat
awareness training,
so people went blindfolded,
have to become more aware of when
somebody is looking at and we're going
to attack them from behind.
So my question to you,
since this is your world not mine,
is,
is how easy do you think it would be to
train people in threat awareness to
become more sensitive to knowing when
they're being looked at?
That's very interesting.
Um,
I have never been a part of any martial
art that teaches people threat
awareness.
What the martial arts that I've been
involved in have all been about
acquiring very specific skills for hand
to hand combat against other trained
adversaries.
There's a bunch of different types of
martial arts that emphasize what you
call self defense type martial arts.
My issue with those guys and the
practices of self defense type martial
arts,
is that almost everything that they're
teaching would only work against a
non-trained opponent.
Um,
they,
they have all these ideas.
Like if a guy comes at you and throws a
punch,
you grab his wrist,
he do this,
you do that.
All that stuff only works on someone who
doesn't know how to fight.
And my thinking is always learn what
works on trained killers.
Weren't learn things that are undeniable
against the most skilled martial
artists.
Those are the things you want to learn.
And through this practice of very,
very difficult to pull off techniques,
very difficult training,
pushing yourself,
expanding the boundaries of your,
your,
your willingness to push your body and
your mind.
That's how you truly learn about
yourself.
And uh,
me and Milton Musashi had this
expression that he wrote in the book of
five rings that once you understand the
way broadly,
you will see it in all things in that
way.
Being in his world was the way of sword
fighting and that you would understand
this and this most incredible and
intense way and you would see the same
sort of path of of the the True Path in
calligraphy and carpentry and all sorts
of expressive art forms and that this is
my opinion.
What is the great benefit of martial
arts?
It's the developing of your human
potential through this incredibly
difficult endeavor and I've always found
that these guys who like blindfold and
look out for.
It's all bullshit.
There's a tremendous amount of bullshit
in martial arts.
It's one of worst.
Oh,
is it?
Much less so now because of the new
movement from 1993 on has been the
movement of mixed martial arts and
that's because of these things called
the ultimate fighting championship and
mixed martial arts competitions and what
mixed martial arts competitions have
done is there was always these ideas at
different people at death touches and
sky could just.
He could hit you in a certain place and
uses ci and knock you back.
All those guys failed miserably in
competition.
Not a single one was successful.
Not One,
every single one was beaten down and it
just showed there's no mysticism when it
comes to martial arts.
The true mysticism is the conquering of
your fears,
the ability to understand how to remain
calm during these incredibly stressful
moments of competition and through
repetition and intelligent development
of technique.
That's what real martial arts training
teaches people and that any divine
feeling you get from a true master,
you would get from a pianist as well.
You would get from a true,
a brilliant painter.
You know,
you've,
you've met Alex Grey,
right?
Yes.
Brilliant painter,
but you know how that feeling you get
when you're around him,
he's a master.
You don't have any.
Like,
he has this sense of this like very
like,
you know,
you're in the presence of a very unique
person.
And I have experienced that same feeling
when I've been around martial artists
and that same feeling when I've been
around,
you know,
just great minds,
great thinkers.
There's what you do is you recognize
you're recognizing greatness.
You're recognizing what Musashi said.
You're recognizing someone who
understands the way broadly.
And,
um,
I don't,
I don't believe in a lot of these ideas
of self defense training,
you know,
I think there's certain techniques that
are very effective for soldiers like
disarmament techniques,
like how to take someone's pistol away,
how to,
uh,
how to defend against a knife attack
where it's very technique oriented.
A Krav Maga incorporates a lot of those,
which is an Israeli martial art that
takes a lot of the best aspects of many
different martial arts.
And they,
uh,
they train that.
Um,
there are definitely real techniques
involved that have been taught to
soldiers and by soldiers when it comes
to disarmament,
when it comes to how to deal with a hand
to hand combat in certain situations.
But I think overall,
a lot of the quote unquote selfdefence
styles are bullshit and a lot of the,
uh,
you know,
we're gonna blindfold.
You and people are going to kick you.
If I blindfold you,
you're going to get fucked up.
All right?
If I blindfold you,
there's not a person alive is gonna.
Stop me from putting him in the face.
If I blindfold them,
you're not going to know what's coming.
The only thing that you could help is if
you have control of a body.
Like if you're blindfolded,
you can grapple very well.
But I could.
I've grappled with my eyes closed
before,
but the reason being is that if I am
holding onto your waist,
if I have a hold of you,
I know where everything else is just
a,
a pattern thing.
It's a,
it's a pattern recognition.
I've,
I've been in that position so many times
that I could.
I know where your neck is going to be.
I know where your arm's going to be.
If I isolate your shoulder,
I know where your wrist is going to be.
I know how to isolate those joints
without having to look at them.
So in that sense,
you could do some things blindfolded but
not striking distance.
I think the threat awareness stuff was
not so much that you could fight
blindfolded,
but training people to feel from which
direction someone was looking at behind
it seems to be plausible.
You could train that.
Um,
but you know,
it's not my world.
And so really the,
I mean this is an issue that if,
if they ask my advice on experimental
design,
but I do for threat awareness is this,
I'd have say take a five story building
on one of the five stories selected at
random,
you'd have a,
you do it at night,
have guys hidden behind in officers that
can look at people walking along
corridors.
You'd have CCTV cameras and people
watching them on that floor,
but on the other four floors you'd
switch off the TV cameras and been able
to do that and you'd have somebody walk
through each floor of this building and
then they'd have to say which one they
were being watched in and one out of
five if they got it right.
You know,
lots of times there's a one in five
chance of getting it right just by
guessing.
But if you find results above score
above chance,
you could then say,
well these people are actually detecting
when the potential threats and you might
be able to train people to get better at
it than what you did.
Your study,
correct me if I'm wrong,
you had people sit down and then they.
They would.
They hit a button when they felt someone
looking at them.
No.
What happened was this.
Well,
there's two.
There's two methods.
One,
one method I've mainly used is the
simplest one that you can do with kids
in schools and one person's blind folded
with an airline star,
blindfold,
cut up,
peripheral vision.
The other person sits behind them and
then in random series of trials,
the simplest message is tossing a coin,
but I have random sheets of instructions
in it.
You'd look or you don't look,
so if it's a look looking trial,
the person behind stairs at the back of
their neck and thinks about them,
if it's not,
and then after 10 seconds it doesn't
click and so they hear a click or a
beep.
They know the trials began and within 10
seconds they have to say looking or not
looking,
are you being looked at or not?
Yes or no.
It's right or wrong,
and then the next trial at random would
be looking or not looking and if it's
not looking,
they look away.
And think of something else and people
have to guess.
We usually do 20 of these or any 10
seconds each,
so it doesn't take long and this gives
results where most people score above
chance,
50 percent chance,
but many,
if you take an average,
it comes to around 55 to 60 percent,
so it's not a big effect,
but over hundreds of thousands of trials
that showed something's going on
statistically significant.
It's very significant and if you do it
through windows,
were to eliminate smell or sound or one
way mirrors.
It still works.
And in Amsterdam,
this has been running in the Science
Museum for 20 years and it's one of the
biggest experiments ever conducted.
And the interesting hinders.
The overall results were extremely
positive,
highly significant statistically,
but what they've shown is what I've
already found in my own experience.
The most sensitive subjects are children
under the age of nine.
And I think most of versus when we're
older,
we go out into the world is crowded
streets.
Lots of people look at it,
we desensitize ourselves,
but children are much more sensitive.
I wonder if that case,
I wonder if really attractive woman
would be the worst at it because really
attractive women are used to putting on
blindfolds and walking past people
staring at them all the time.
Yes.
Well,
there is a slight difference in those
who've experienced this.
More women than men have experienced
being stared at and do service and more
men than women have experienced turning
it others and looking at others,
making them turnaround manner.
Liras.
Yes.
So attractive women do have to,
as you say,
they have,
um,
they have to learn to avoid meeting
people's gaze.
Photograph American girl in Italy from
1951.
It's a fascinating photograph.
It's a famous photograph.
This American woman is walking down the
street next to these animals,
these men that are grabbing their crotch
and they're there stare and she has this
look on her face.
She's not looking at anyone in
particular.
She's just going straight forward.
And I'm like,
that woman would be like a perfect
candidate.
Someone who's like to blocking off all
these leering yes.
Freaks.
They're staring at her.
When you,
um,
was there anyone that you'd ever done
that study on that was like really good
at it?
Like 75 percent?
Eighty percent.
Oh,
100 percent.
Yes.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
Someone got 100 percent.
Yes.
And that was my oldest son,
Merlin,
Merlin.
The wizard when Sunday.
Merlin?
Yes.
Ridiculous.
He's a scientist.
He's a phd at the moment.
And in tropical Dr Merlin.
Wow.
In the younger,
my youngest son who's 24 is a musician.
It's 100 percent.
Yes.
When melon was four years old,
I did this experiment with him,
you know,
blindfolds.
Him.
He's sitting there.
I said,
look,
I'm going to look at you some of the
time.
The rest of the time.
Nice.
And each time you hear this click,
you have to say if you think you're
being looked at,
he got it right 100 percent of the time.
So I couldn't believe this.
He wasn't cheating.
I mean he didn't know about cheating.
He was four.
Four.
Wow.
And so I did it again,
his brilliance,
and he said,
Daddy,
you've done to.
Can we do it the other way round?
Can you tell when I'm looking at you?
So I said,
okay,
we'll try that.
And we did it the other way around and I
out of 20 trials I got sorta 11 out of
20.
It was above chance,
but I was wrong quite lots of time.
Then he got the idea,
well you can be wrong and I was wrong
and sort of changed his mind and after
that when they test him,
it was still fairly high,
75 percent,
but he never got 100 percent again.
That's interesting.
And what were the numbers like?
How many times did you do it?
Well the first two times were 20 times
20.
So normally I do these trials with 20
trials and most people would get say 11
out of 20 and he was getting $20
definitely.
Which is hugely significant to course.
And um,
anyway,
the thing is that young children are
very,
very sensitive to this.
And I hold yours forensics,
the younger ones you see,
check it out.
I've already got my plans for tonight.
I'm going to go on the way home and pick
up some blindfolds.
Yeah,
that's,
ah,
that's brilliant.
That's really interesting.
The idea that you introduced the
possibility of failure and then he was
like,
oh,
and then he doubt crept in.
Exactly,
and the problem with the kinds of tests
side,
I do tests on the sense of being stared
at telepathy.
I've joked doing a lot on telephone
telepathy.
Can you tell who's calling?
I'm the problem with these kinds of
experiments is that you have to set them
up so that people could be right or
wrong and Pete know very few people are
right all the time,
but as soon as doubt creeps in the mind
and fierce people think,
oh,
maybe I guess one way last time it's
statistically I shouldn't be the other
way this time.
And,
and they start,
as soon as that kind of thing goes on,
people lose it.
Boy,
that is life in a nutshell,
isn't it?
Like as soon as you have doubt,
your whole world is just a mess and
unfortunately these experiments that I
do introduce doubt into the vet because
I have to do statistical experiments
that have incredible to skeptics.
So there's a kind of skepticism built
into the experiment.
I haven't yet found a way of doing this.
I'm always.
The holy grail would be to find ways of
doing these tests where people don't
realize that they're being tested and
that could be doubt.
How could that be done though?
Well,
I'm thinking of one kind of test that
will be incorporated in a video game
where say you have to choose between
going through one door,
another door and one door.
You go through it.
It's absolutely awful.
In the other door you escape and you're
onto sort of next stage.
You could have it where when people
choose it hasn't been decided.
You'd have a random event thing that
would determine which door you go
through after you've made the choice to
go through it.
This is then called presettlement or pre
cognition.
It's like knowing the future and so if
people were right more often than they
were wrong,
you'd know because it purely chance it
should be 50 slash 50.
If some people were coming out 60,
40,
you wouldn't say this is a psychological
test.
You would say,
you know,
how lucky are you and can you be
consistently lucky in this?
Um,
and it would be more like luck.
It would still involve now them to duck
because you might start thinking,
oh,
I'm not very lucky today.
Um,
but it would be,
wouldn't be framed as a,
as a,
a scientific experiment.
It will.
We've framed as a way of training your
ability to be lucky.
Well,
hmm.
Training your ability to be lucky.
Yes.
Intuition is a very strange thing and
some people believe in it and some
people don't.
Some people believe that you make good
choices.
Like you know,
you'll,
you'll hear people that are successful
that are confident and again,
Hey,
I've always been lucky.
I've got great instincts,
but that there is something to
instincts.
There's something to trusting certain
folks and not trusting certain folks
based on just an immediately the feeling
you get when you meet them.
Some things just don't seem bright.
And I think a lot of it is probably
pattern recognition.
A lot of it is,
you know,
I've been around guys like this before.
I know what they're about.
This guy's just got a little bit of
bullshit and um,
I gotta get Outta here,
you know?
Well,
I think the intuition just means direct
knowing and some of it can be
telepathic.
Some of it can be unconscious pattern
recognition.
There's lots of components,
but some of them,
I think what you could call Paris
psychological,
you know,
feeling the future or picking up things
telepathically.
Um,
and you know,
these recent experiments of daryl bem at
cornell on feeding the future.
I don't know if you've looked into
those.
Let me just keep an eye on the time.
It's 1:00.
Okay.
Well you have a pocket watch old school
look at you with a chain on it.
Yes.
Wow.
I don't like wearing wristwatches.
Let me take that out.
How do you have connected to your belt
or something?
Yes.
Savor the trousers is.
Wow.
Pretty Slick.
So where's the park at watch?
Well,
you know,
you need to know the time sometimes.
Watches.
I don't like being manacled to time.
I'm cold.
Yeah.
You carry a cell phone?
No.
Oh,
you're one of those guys.
Yeah.
How come?
I hate being interrupted.
You know,
I don't like the phone at home.
I don't use phones much.
I might use email.
That's fine.
I can always just shut your phone off.
I know,
but I'd rather not have it.
I do have one because I.
I'm doing experiments on cell phones on
telephone.
Telepathy is my friend Steve was talking
about from London.
Same thing.
Hates,
hates having a phone drive.
His wife crazy.
Yes.
Well that's a good reason for not having
one.
I don't want to be interrupted all the
time and if I go for a walk or if I'm
working or.
So I find it really annoying if the
phone rings.
I mean anyway,
the pocket watch means I can know the
time and I need to know I'm going to
have to go fairly soon,
but not quite yet.
Um,
where were we to let potential efficacy
tests?
Um,
and intuition sometimes it's Interior
Daryl bams experiments.
I'm a very simple and it's called
feeling the future and does this
phenomenon that dean raging at the
Institute of noetic sciences has done a
lot of research on where it turns out
that we can respond a few seconds before
an emotionally arousing event.
Our body starts preparing for it before
it happens.
This would be very relevant to fast
sports,
Ping Pong,
tennis,
cricket,
downhill skiing,
and probably martial arts as well.
Um,
and this research seems to me pretty
convincing.
Uh,
I've been a subject in some of these
experiments myself and the dean raging
rational.
It is this,
you sit there in front of a computer
screen,
you're wearing electrodes that measure
emotional arousal,
you know,
adrenaline causes sweating and emotional
arousal like a lie detector.
So it's a standard way of measuring
emotional arousal when you read,
you press a button and 10 seconds later
a picture appears on the screen.
Most of the pictures are neutral,
you know,
landscapes,
bold of flyers or something like that.
I'm vaguely pleasant.
Some of them are scenes that are
emotionally arousing hardcore
pornography or scenes of extreme
violence.
Now,
almost everybody,
when they see hardcore pornography or
scenes that fondness who's emotionally
aroused,
even if they don't want to be,
they they,
they are,
and the lie detector thing shows a huge
emotional arousal.
But the interesting thing in these
experiments is the emotional arousal
begins about five seconds before the
picture appears on the screen,
five seconds,
long time for,
for,
for people ready,
here's five seconds,
go
five seconds.
That's a long time.
And so the body,
the heart starts beating faster.
The fight or flight response.
So you know,
the adrenaline kind of response kicks
in.
So when the,
when the stimulus occurs,
the body's already sort of revved up
with this emotional response.
Now this is what that,
that,
um,
dean regions done.
He's repeated it and it's been
replicated elsewhere,
is called pre sentiment feeling,
the feeling and then trans,
um,
and a decision as to which picture
appears on the screen is made by the
computer a millisecond before it
actually appears.
There's no one in the world knows what
picture is going to appear.
Now this is really interesting,
you see,
because it shows those a kind of feeding
back of emotion.
No,
Daryl Bem at Cornell who's a very
respected professor of psychology and
has been doing a different kind of
experiment which doesn't involve the lie
detector,
um,
his experiments and you sit in front of
a computer screen and there's two
curtains.
They're behind one of those curtains.
There's a blank wall,
an image of a blank wall behind the
other one.
Those upon a graphic image.
Now,
most people,
even if they don't normally watch
pornography and more interested in
seeing a pornographic image than a blank
wall.
And before you do the test,
you do as a simple questionnaire,
you gay,
straight,
etc.
So people who are gay,
gay,
pornographic images.
So those are emotionally arousing.
Say what happens?
You sit down at the computer and you
click on one of those two cartons,
which,
which one you want to click on,
choose which of the two.
It's random whether you'll get the wall
or the pornographic image.
And so you click on one and most people
would hope that they're going to see the
pornographic image,
a different one each time.
And um,
and the computer makes the decision
which one to roll back which cotton roll
back after you've made.
The people don't know that there's
decisions only made by the computer
after they've decided they think it's
already there.
Um,
so most people don't know that they're
doing a pre sentiment test.
Um,
so what happens is in these experiments
about 53 or 54 percent of the time,
people get the pornographic image,
whereas by pure chance they would be 50
percent.
And if instead of a pornographic image
you have a sort of mildly pleasant
landscape or something that's not
emotionally arousing,
it's down to 50 percent.
Whoa.
So this is telling us that something
about emotional arousal can work back in
time.
And when you think about fast sports,
imagine you know,
tennis people are saving at 90 miles an
hour.
There's not time for the eye to take in
the angle of the ball to process it in
the brain through clunky brain
processing,
to send messages along the nerves to
muscles to get the whole body ready or
in a penalty shoot out.
The goalie haS to,
in a football soccer match the,
they have to react very quickly.
And in,
in ping pong,
you have to react quickly.
And cricket people,
australian fast bowlers bowling 100
miles an hour in cricket,
um,
does not long enough.
And in downhill skiing,
you come around a corner.
Um,
it's,
it's too fast.
So,
um,
I think that part of our,
the way we're reacting,
and I think this comes up most in sports
is it,
and it would also come out driving a car
if you got the five second and advance
warning some accidents,
but hatton you could concentrate and
perhaps avoid it and better.
And this is a fascinating field of
research which,
um,
is it,
is not yet been picked up by a sports
psychologists or by.
I've told Several people in the military
about it because I think it Would be
really interesting.
I don't think it's going to do any harm
if they know know this,
but say for example,
you had your physiology being monitored,
you're in a flight simulator or a
driving simulator and say you had it so
that when you've got an otherwise
inexplicably emotional arousal going on,
will you be unconscious of it to start
with,
say it was wild outside red light went
on in the cockpit of the drive flight
simulator.
It might sometimes be a false alarm,
but every time that light went on you
the message we concentrate harder,
something bad might happen and this
could be useful technological candidate.
And so I think this is,
you know,
there's a lot of potential in this kind
of research which is only just being
began to be explored.
Um,
and the reason I've encouraged people in
the british defense research
establishment to do this is because
they're more likely to take it up than
people in universities.
Because in universities,
you know,
there's this kind of dogmatic skepticism
that means people are,
it's rubbish,
it's,
whew,
it's pseudo science,
et cetera.
I mean stupid reactions really at the,
the,
the most interesting in actually,
yes,
this is really interesting.
Can we find out more and can we apply
it?
That's incrediblY fascinating.
Do you think that these things like this
is pre pre cognition ability or this uh,
instincts or these,
the ability to recognize these patterns.
do you think this is possibly some
emerging thing in,
in human beings?
Emerging aspect of the development of
humans mean obviously if you believe in
evolution,
we were one thing now we are this,
we are what we are now,
which is radically different from the
pre human hominids have 2 million plus
years ago were very,
very different.
If you just extrapolate a million years
from now,
we're going to be very different from
what we are now.
Do you think that this aspect of human
beings of human life is as a,
as a developing thing,
this pre cognition ability,
this ability to communicate with each
other.
Do you think maybe that's what's
manifesting itself when you,
when you think about someone and also on
the phone rings and it's them like
instantaneously?
Well,
I think that is
being in traditional societies,
that's actually a better development in
modern ones where there's people don't
talk about it on the whole,
there's no training for it and stuff.
In traditional societies,
people take these things for granted and
they rely on them.
Now the phone is an interesting case
because this is a modern technology,
but I think that telepathy as a means of
communication between people who know
each other well is actually.
It's always been going on.
Animals have it.
I've been doing research on telepathy
and dogs.
I wrote a book called dogs that know
when they're coming home.
I did lots of experiments on our dogs
picking it up just by routine or cars
hands.
The answer is no.
We filmed them.
We have people come at random times in
unfamiliar vehicles.
the dog still on there,
but why have people have such a hard
time replicating those dog?
One's been application.
It was replicated by a skeptic who then
pretended he hadn't replicated it.
Um,
but it's now generally agreed that his
results agreed perfectly with my end.
And millions of people have dogs that do
this.
So I don't think it's hard to replicate,
it's just that if you do this in a
university,
it's likely to end your career.
Yeah.
what is that?
What it is?
Because I've read online people that
have disagreed with you saying that no
one has ever replicated your your
results.
Oh yes.
well that's.
That's the skeptics disinformation.
It's been replicated by one of the
leading skeptics in britain who then
pretended falsely that he hadn't.
And who was that?
Richard wiseman and online on my website
you can see his data plotted on graphs
showing exactly the same effect as I
found.
Is it statistically significant or is it
100 percent is statistically significant
data and mine.
What is your data like?
How,
how?
How often do they know and how often
were they unaware?
About 80 percent of the time.
We did a series of 100 trials with one
dog and on those occasions the dog
started waiting.
When the person was about to come home,
it was actually before she got in the
car to come home,
all the taxi picked up her intention and
this was at random times on 20 occasions
out of 100.
it didn't on three or four of those,
the dog was sick and on the other
occasions it was when it was a bit john
heat and the next apartment could be
distracted,
but even if you include all hundred
events including the ones where the dog
was to do the statistics,
it's still massively significant.
That's fascInating.
So you think that much like what you
were talking about with your son who is
able to recognize 100 percent of the
time when someone was staring at him
that dogs,
because they don't have like a cultural
context,
they don't have all this doubt in their
head that they do it and they have an
emotional investment too.
It's not like a boring paris psychology
experiment in it for a dog is immensely
emotionally exciting.
when the owner comes home is an
emotional charge.
They do it over and over again.
They never get bored of their own.
Is coming home,
so this is the telephone phenomenon,
which I can briefly summarize is one I
do in my tests.
People who say this happens to them in
real life,
give me the names and numbers of four
people.
It might happen with a we pick,
they sit at home being filmed so we know
they're not getting other phone calls or
text messages or something.
And they are a landline on the landline
phone with no caller id display.
We picked one of the four corners at
random and I'm called them out and say
if you were doing it was say please ring
joe.
No.
And um,
they think about you,
they bring you your phone rings and
before you pick it up you have to say
who you think it is.
Yeah,
I think it's john and you pick it up.
Say hi john,
you're right or you're wrong.
You can't know from the normal patterns
of life because the,
um,
it's a randomly chosen.
And so by chance you'd be right one time
in four,
25 percent in these experiments.
The Average score in our film test is 45
percent and massively significant
statistically,
and this has not been replicated in
other universities.
Even one of britain's leading skeptics
checked us out and he's getting positive
results much to his dismay.
And so this is a.
I've now got an automated test.
I'm about to launch it in the us,
but it's already launched in britain
where people can do this on cell phones
with their friends.
You don't have to be in a lab.
Um,
I think telephone telepathy is real and
I think what's happening is that when
you want to call someone,
if I wanted to call you,
I'd formed the intention to call you.
I've got a motive to call you.
They'd be thinking about joe and then
I'd get my phone out.
I dial a number or press your memory
thing for you.
When I formed the intention to call you.
I think you could in some cases pickup
that intention.
You might start thinking about me for no
apparent reason.
And then the call comes through and you
say,
it's funny,
I was just thinking about you.
So I think this is a genuinely
telepathic phenomenon in many cases.
Sometimes it can be coincidence,
but on average it seems to be a real
effect.
And um,
I think this is an example of where
telepathy really is evolving along with
technology.
It happens with emails and text messages
as well.
Until recently,
the only way you could get in touch with
someone at a distance was telepathically
if you wanted a quick response.
Now you can do it by phone.
And I've also done research on what I
think is one of the basic biological
forms of this which mothers and babies,
many nursing mothers find that when
they're away from their baby for no
apparent reason,
their milk that's done,
their breasts start squeezing out milk
normally.
That happens when the baby cries and
they feel their breast tinkle.
Say there was a nursing mother here now
and there was no baby crying here and
she felt her milk that done.
Most nursing mothers think my baby needs
me.
And until recently they just went home
to the baby.
Now they call home on a cell phone.
But I've done studies on nursing mothers
in london,
20 of them over two month period each,
and we found that there was.
it was very,
very highly significant.
It wasn't just synchronized rhythms.
They were responding when they baby
needed them and before telephones were
invented,
any mother that could pick up when her
baby needed her and went to the baby
would have a mother,
a baby that survived better than a
mother,
didn't pick it up.
So I think telephones in a way,
it gives us a technological way of doing
something that in the past happened more
unreliably by telepathy.
So do you think that these telephones
connecting to telepathy is somehow or
another related to this,
this morphic field that it's seemingly
undefined?
We don't.
We know.
Or rather you believe that this is a
real phenomenon,
that it exists,
but we don't know exactly what the
mechanism is.
Yeah.
I think what happens with social groups,
any social group,
is that the field as a whole,
as a group,
as a whole,
has a field,
like a magnetic field will arrange on
filings which are within its field of
influence.
If you have a flock of birds,
starlings that are flying together,
there's a kind of field that coordinates
their movement so they can change
direction rapidly without bumping into
each other.
If you hAve a school of fish,
you got the same kind of thing.
If you have a pack of wolves and they
leave the young,
the cubs are left behind in the den with
a babysitter while the adults go hunting
to bring food back for the young.
The field that links them isn't broken.
It stretches like an invisible elastic
band.
I think that's the basis of telepathy.
I think it's to do with social bonds
through social fields.
And a mother and the baby are very
closely linked and it's as if there's
this invisible elastic band between
them.
And so when you look at telephone
telepathy,
it typically only happens with people
you know.
Well,
it happens between mothers and children.
Husbands and wives,
lovers,
partners,
um,
therapists and clients.
If there's a kind of emotional charge,
best friends,
it doesn't happen with insurance
salesman and,
and people to whom you're not
emotionally connected.
Um,
it's a,
it depends on social bonds.
And so I think morphic fields of the
social group is something that applies
to any social group.
A family as a kind of has a morphic
field,
a football team has won a Michael Murphy
who founded the esalen institute,
did a fascinating book called the
psychic side of sports.
And um,
he describes these interviews with
football players and many of them turned
quite mystical when they were
interviewed in private.
They wouldn't talk about it in the
locker room for fear of being thought
weird.
Um,
but many of them,
like soccer players,
they said when the game's going,
well,
it's as if they can just feel where
other people are on the field.
It was like an instinct even they
didn't,
they just,
somehow they were working like a single
organism.
And I think that's an example of a
morphic field of a social group.
And I think that's why team sports,
I'm,
uh,
so interesting to watch because it's not
just about guys being brilliant,
it's about guys working together and in
a way that's highly coordinated and more
effectively the team works together.
The more effective it is.
That's fascinating.
Staff.
It's really interesting to consider how
much of a factor that does play.
What did it,
what exactly it is too.
Yeah.
Now it's an amazing,
uh,
you're out of time.
Rupert sheldrake,
rupert sheldrake.org.
Is your website a rupert sheldrake.org?
I'm just sheldrake.org.
And rupert sheldrake is
your twitter handle?
correct?
Do you handle all that stuff?
I,
I tried.
I didn't really use twitter,
so no,
forget that.
Really do have one,
but I don't use it.
Someone set it up for me and I never
learned.
Her last tweet was September 13th.
I posted a new photo.
The facebook.
Oh,
so you use facebook?
facebook has automatically,
yes.
To twitter.
Uh,
thank you very much man.
Really appreciate this.
It's really cool to have a conversation
with you after listening to you in the
trial logs a.
I really appreciated it and we can do
this anytime you're in town.
Okay.
Well it's fun for me too.
I've really enjoyed it.
How often are you in la?
The last time was 27 years ago,
so I got lucky.
I goT lucky.
Alright.
Thank you very much.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Rupert sheldrake.
Ladies and gentlemen,
uh,
we'll see you thursday with a graham
hancock.
Until then,
much love big kiss.
This podcast is brought to you by blue
apron.
Go to blue apron.com
forward slash rogen for your first two
meals for free.
That's blue apron.com.
Forward slash rogen were also brought to
you by stamps.com.
Go to stamps.com.
Enter the code word j r e and get your
$110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to
$55 in free postage.
And last but not least,
we are brought to you by [inaudible] dot
com,
but it's o,
n n I t dot d's the codeword rogan.
And you will save 10 percent off any and
all sub.